THE SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE
WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE'RE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE AT THE CAPITOL AND NONE OF
OUR MEMBERS ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. IN THE SENATE CHAMBER
WITH ME OUR SENATORS CORTESE
DELHI GLAZER REQUIRE OCHO
ALTHOUGH CAMPAIGNED. WE ALSO
HAVE REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
SAMBAR DINO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION YMCA OF SAN DIEGO.
PART OF LOS NINOS CHILD ACTION
PARENT VOICES PARTNERSHIP FOR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH AND CHILD
CARE RESOURCE CENTER. FOR A
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE
UNMUTE PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONES
OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL GREATLY
AID ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I ASKED EVERY TIME YOU
WISH TO RECOGNIZE THAT USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME WE'RE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING YOU IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ADMIT THEM
MUTE. PLACES SELECT A NEW BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING OUR I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE AMITTED MEMBERS
OFTHE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING
ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. I
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TELEPORT TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INTO WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE FOUR ONE
EIGHT FIVE. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS FOUR SIX SIX. THREE NINE SIX
EIGHT. FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
INDOOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. FOR
TODAY'S HEARING WILL BE PUT ON
WE WILL BE HEARING ALL OF THE
PANELS OF WITNESSES ON THE
AGENDA PRIOR TO TAKING ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT. WHAT WE HAVE
HEARD ALL OF THE WITNESSES WE
WILL HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
COMMENT ON TODAY'S TOPICS OF THE
GENDER. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK
YOU MUST MEET THE DEVICE FOR
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR
FROM YOU WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MEAN THE COURT
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE AND HELP OR HAVE
THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED. ALL
RIGHT LET'S BEGIN THE HEARING.
THE PURPOSE OF TODAY'S HEARING
IS TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW ON THE
STATE'S EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
AND EXPANDED LEARNING PROGRAMS
AND HOW THESE SYSTEMS MEET THE
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES. THE PROGRAMS
WITHIN OUR EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION SYSTEM HAVE VARYING
FUNDING SOURCES. REQUIREMENTS
FOR STAFF. STAFFING RATIOS HOURS
OF OPERATION AND FAMILY FEE
STRUCTURES. THE SYSTEM IS
OVERSEEN BY TWO ADMINISTERING
AGENCIES. THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. IN ADDITION OUR
EXPANDED LEARNING PROGRAMS HAVE
DIFFERENT SOURCES OF FUNDING AND
PROGRAMMATIC REQUIREMENTS. THAN
THE PROGRAMS WITHIN OUR EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION SYSTEM. BOTH
PROGRAM TYPES HAVE RECEIVED A
LOT OF ATTENTION DURING THE
PANDEMIC. AS WE RECOGNIZE THAT
CARE IS ESSENTIAL FOR KEEPING
CHILDREN ENGAGED IN LEARNING.
AND KEEPING THE ECONOMY RUNNING.
CHILDREN LEARN AND ARE CARED FOR
IN A VARIETY OF SETTINGS SUCH AS
CENTERS HOME BASED CARE. AN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL SITES. WE NEED
TO UNDERSTAND HOW THESE SYSTEMS
AND PROGRAMS INTERSECT OR
COMPLIMENT OR CONFLICT WITH EACH
OTHER. AND HELP FAMILIES COBBLE
TOGETHER A FULL DAY OF CARE AND
LEARNING FOR THEIR CHILD AND
CHILDREN OF DIFFERENT AGES. AS
WE CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
EXPANDING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
YOUNG CHILDREN TO HAVE ACCESS TO
HIGH QUALITY AND DEVELOPMENTALLY
APPROPRIATE PROGRAMS. WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT THE STATE IS
SUPPORTING CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
AND THE CARE AND EDUCATION
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT SUPPORT
THESE PROGRAMS AND STAFF. WE
SHOULD DESIGN BOTH SYSTEMS WITH
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES A THE
CENTER AND WITH POLICIES THAT
EMPOWER PARENTS AND STAFF AS
EXPERTS TO BEST MEET THE NEEDS
OF OUR COMMUNITIES. OR WE BEGIN
WITH OUR SPEAKERS I WOULD LIKE
TO INVITE THE PUBLIC WANTING TO
PURSUE DISSIPATE TO CALL IN NOW.
PLEASE DIAL THIS TOLL FREE
NUMBER. 844-291-4185 WHEN
PROMPTED. PLEASE USE THIS ACCESS
CODE. FOUR SIX SIX THREE NINE
SIX EIGHT NOW LET'S HEAR FROM
OUR FIRST PRESENTER EDGAR CABRAL
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE MR CABRAL WELCOME PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AND GROUP OF ALL THE LIVES OF
OUR OFFICE. I WOULD HAVE TO
PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE-
THE- CHILDCARE AND EXPANDED
LEARNING PROGRAMS THAT THE STATE
HAS FOR SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN. WE
DO NOT WE DO HAVE A HANDLE BUT I
BELIEVE WAS SHARED WITH YOU AND
FOR THOSE WHO ARE WATCHING- THIS
ARE HEARING VIRTUALLY IT SHOULD
BE AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE L.
A. O. DOT CA. GOP YOU TO BE ON
THE RIGHT HAND SIDE OF THE OF
THE PAGE I'M IN THE JUST A
BRIEF- A HIGH LEVEL I KNOW THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF DETAILS A
STRIP. OR SOMETHING OF THE KEY
ASPECTS AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER. ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE. AND SO THE FIRST PAGE OF
OUR OF OUR OUT WE HAVE. A PEOPLE
THAT COMPARES. THE MAJOR CHUNK
OF PROGRAMS FOR SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN- AND SO WHAT HAPPENS.
WHEN A TEAM OF THE FOLKS THAT I
TALK ABOUT GRAHAM'S- TALKING
ABOUT- PROGRAMS ARE PRIMARILY
ADMINISTERED THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF. SOCIAL SERVICES
AND THE PRIMARY GOAL IS. TO
PROVIDE- CURRENT OPTION FOR
TUCKER WHILE THEY'RE WORKING. ON
WE HAVE COME TO DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES OF THOSE PROGRAMS WE
HAVE- CENTER BASED VOUCHER
PROGRAMS- WHICH CAN BE- PRIVATE
PROVIDERS- AND- COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS- THAT. THAT
PROVIDES SERVICES- FAMILIES
RECEIVE A VOUCHER IN THE MAKING
BUT WOULD CHOOSE. WHICH PROGRAM
THEY WANT THEY WANT TO ENROLL
IN. A MEMBER STATE HAS DIRECT
CONTRACTORS. WHICH ARE ARE
PROVIDERS WHO CONTRACT DIRECTLY
WITH THE STATE I'M REALLY
THROUGH THE GENERAL TUCKER
PROGRAM AND THEN FOR STATE
PRESCHOOL THROUGH THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM- AND- AND-
BASER ELIGIBLE CHILDREN- WHO.
WHO CAN IDENTIFY DIRECTLY. ON IT
AS AS YOU CAN SEE ON ON ON YOUR
CHART UNDER A LOT OF
SIMILARITIES. PROGRAMS THE-
BASED ON CHANGES YEAR THE FIRM
RAIDS ARE AS IN THE SAME THING
THAT- MARKET RATES FOR EACH
COUNTY. I'M THEY HAVE SIMILAR
STOCK RATIO- AND THEY ARE BASED
ON OUR FAMILY ELIGIBILITY AND
HOURS OF CARE- THAT'S THE
PRIMARY DIFFERENCE HERE IS THIS
RELATED TO WHETHER IT'S- ABOUT
YOUR FAMILY'S. CHOICE OVER THE
PROGRAM TO GO TO OUR A DIRECT
CONTRACT WITH FAMILIES ARE
COMING DIRECTLY. FROM THE
TEACHER QUALIFICATIONS ARE ALSO
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT AND THAT THE
CONTRACT BASED- THE DRUG
CONTRACTORS HAVE SOMEONE HIGHER-
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE NUMBER OF.
COLLEGE CREDITS AND SPECIFICALLY
EARLY CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT
UNITS AS WELL- UP IN THE. TWO TO
BE STUCK IN THE PROGRAM. I
SPEAKING ABOUT HAVING THESE PRO
COMPARED THE OTHER THE SCHOOL
BASED PROGRAMS I WILL TALK ABOUT
IT'S ONE HUNDRED A COUPLE
KEEPING- ONE OF THAT FAMILY
ELIGIBILITY IS THE STARTING
POINT SO IN ORDER TO BE IN ON
THIS PROGRAM- YOU NEED TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT THAT THE
FARMERS DEMONSTRATE THE BAY-
THEY ARE BELOW THE INCOME
THRESHOLD WHICH IS 85% OF THE
CITY STATE MEDIAN INCOME. WHICH
COMES OUT TO SEVENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND FOR A FAMILY OF THREE-
AND THEN THAT THERE IS A NEED
FOR CARE WHILE THE PARENTS ARE
WORKING OR IN SCHOOL OR LOOKING
FOR JOBS- SO THE PROVIDERS HOURS
CAN VERY- THEIR AVAILABILITY BUT
THE GOAL IS JUST TO SPECIFICALLY
PROVIDE THE AMOUNT OF CARE
NECESSARY PERFECT FOR FAMILIES
TO WORK TO GO TO SCHOOL TO LOOK
FOR WORK- AND THEN EVERYTHING
THAT'S THAT'S ONE OF THE KEY
DIFFERENCES FROM THIS PROGRAM
FROM FROM FROM THE SCHOOL BASED
PROGRAMS. THE OTHER KEY IS THAT-
NO ALTHOUGH SOME SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS MAY BE ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES IT'S NOT TYPICAL THESE
ARE TYPICALLY RUN BY PRIVATE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS-
THE AREA THEY'RE NOT NECESSARILY
YOU KNOW- YOU KNOW ON A SCHOOL
CAMPUS ARE NOT DESIGNED.
SPECIFICALLY AROUND SCHOOL- SO
I'M NOMINAL WATER ON THE ON THE
NEXT WE OUR A CHART THAT WALK
THROUGH THE MAIN LONG EXPAND
LEARNING FOR THAT WORK BETTER
SCHOOL BASED- AND THE TWO
PROGRAMS ARE ONE OF THE ASUS
PROGRAM AFTER SCHOOL EDUCATION
FIFTY PROGRAM WHICH IS THE STATE
FUNDED PROGRAM AND THEN THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY- COMMUNITY
LEARNING CENTERS WHICH IS THE
FEDERAL FUNDED PROGRAM- THERE
ARE A LOT OF SMALL DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THE PROGRAMS BUT I WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE KEY THINGS
THAT AGAIN WE DISTINGUISH THEM
FROM THE OTHER PROGRAMS. FIRST-
THE IS SOME SIMILAR. WITH THE
DIRECT. OF EMPLOYMENT THERE.
GRANTS AWARDED SPECIFIC SCHOOL
SITES- SO THERE IS A AN
APPLICATION PROCESS THAT YOU
NEED TO APPLY FOR JOBS TO BE
ABLE TO RECEIVE THE GRANT
FUNDING- AND THEN THE PRIORITY
IS PROVIDED TO THOSE SCHOOLS
THAT ARE SERVING HIGHER
PROPORTIONS OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS. I'M THE ONE KEY
DIFFERENCE THOUGH THE PROGRAM
ELIGIBILITY IS NOT LIMITED TO
LOW INCOME. SO IF THEY THE
SCHOOL SITE KEVIN THIS IS CRAP.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE ONLY SERVE
KIDS WHO WILL MEET IN
COMPRESSION BUT- AND THERE THERE
IS NO SORT OF INCOME ELIGIBILITY
TO BE ABLE TO ENROLL- SCHOOLS
MAY USE- INCOME. THE FAMILY'S
INCOME TO SAY PRIORITIZE THAT
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH SPACE FOR
EVERYBODY. OR THEY MIGHT- THEY
MIGHT DO SOMETHING LIKE THAT BUT
THEY DON'T. THEY ARE NOT
PROHIBITED FROM CERTAIN
QUESTIONS- SIMILARLY THEY THEY
CAN CHOOSE TO- CHARGE FAMILY
FEES ARE FOR THOSE FAMILIES WERE
NOT LOW INCOME SO UNDER THE ASUS
PROGRAM IN THE 20% TO PROGRAM-
AT. PROGRAMS CANNOT CHARGE FEES
FOR OUR FAMILIES TO QUALIFY FOR
FREE AND REDUCED PRICE MEALS.
FOR HOMELESS YOUTH OF. FOR OTHER
FAMILIES IT IS OPTIONAL AND SO
IN SOME CASES THERE MAY BE SOME.
FAMILIES ARE PAYING. I'M THIS
PROGRAM ARE BUILT PRIMARY AROUND
THE SCHOOL DAY AND THIS YEAR- ON
A SCHOOL SO IF THIS- TYPICALLY
WILL. FROM WHEN SCHOOL ENDS
THREE SELECT PM SIX PM AT LEAST
- SOMETIMES CAN BE A BEFORE
SCHOOL COMPONENT OR SOME KIND OF
SUMMER COMPONENT BUT THAT'S NOT
COMMON. ON THESE ARE TYPICALLY-
HELPING TO SORT OF BRIDGE THE
GAP BETWEEN THE SCHOOL AND THE
SCHOOL DAY ENDS. AND RAN-
PARENTS ARE ARE OUT OF WORK- BUT
THERE IS NOT A SPECIFIC- SERVICE
THE REPORT THAT THAT THAT THIS
PROGRAM. IS IT ADAPTING ON THE
NEEDS OF THE WORK MEET THE
PARENTS- AND ALTHOUGH THIS
FUNDING GO. IT GOES TO SCHOOLS
AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS. BY- WE DON'T HAVE A
SPECIFIC DATE ON THIS BUT IN MY
HEART WE TALKED TO- SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OPERATE THESE
PROGRAMS. BY AND LARGE THESE
PROGRAMS- OUR STAFF THROUGH
PARTNERSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THEMSELVES-
ALTHOUGH THE FUNDING GOES
DIRECTLY TO SCHOOLS MAYBE SORT
OF VISION PLAN IMPORTANT ROLE IN
BOTH. THE THE START TALKING
PROGRAM THAT I MENTIONED EARLIER
AND SCHOOL BASED PROGRAMS. GOOD
NOW- MILLER. TURTLE PAGE OF OUR
CHART TO TALK ABOUT THE EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM
SO THIS IS A NEW PROGRAM THAT
WAS CREATED. LAST YEAR IN THE
BUDGET- A SCHOOL BASED- PROGRAM
OF THE STATE PROVIDED ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS IN
PROVENTIA FUNDING IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO TO ESTABLISH THE
PROGRAM. AND THERE IS- THE
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE HAD INTENT
THAT. IT THE PROGRAM WILL REACH
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS BY TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX- AND THE
GOVERNORS BUT THIS YEAR INCLUDES
FUNDING TO GET THE PROGRAM UP TO
FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
ALMOST ALL THE WAY THROUGH. I
BELIEVE. I AM. BUT WE WOULD KNOW
IF THERE. IF THIS PROGRAM WERE
TO EXPAND AT THE AS INTENDED TO
GET UP TO FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING IN THIS
PROGRAM- WHAT'S GOING BUT HE'LL
BE PROGRAMS. WOULD IT WOULD
EXCEED THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
THAT WE PROVIDE FOR ALL THE
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT I'VE ALREADY
MENTIONED SO IT'S A VERY
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE IN FUNDING-
AND HAS THE POTENTIAL TO SERVE A
LOT MORE CHILDREN THAN WE
CURRENTLY DO- UNDER OUR CURRENT
PROGRAMS- THERE. THERE'S SOME.
SIMILAR OF A LOT OF THE ELEMENTS
OF BETA PROGRAM ARE SIMILAR TO
THE STATE AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM
READY- THE STAFFING RATIOS ARE
THE SAME NUMBER. TWENTY CHILDREN
FOR ONE ADULT- THAT MINIMUM
QUALIFICATIONS FOR STAFFING IS
ALSO THE FAME. AND THE SAME
ISSUE OF CHARGING FEES WHETHER
THAT IT'S OPTIONAL BUT YOU
CANNOT CHARGE FEES TO LOW INCOME
FAMILIES ALMOST BEFORE YOU POST.
THOSE COMPONENTS ARE STILL
THERE- THERE ARE SOME KEY. THAT
ARE THAT I WOULD TO HIGHLIGHT-
THE BIGGEST THING IS THAT THIS
IS NOT A COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROGRAMS FUNDING TO PROVIDED TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS. THE FARM THE BETTER- A
PERCENTAGE OF THEIR STUDENTS
THAT ARE- INDICATOR SIX THAT ARE
LOW INCOME OR ENGLISH LEARNERS.
HAPPENING IS PROVIDED FOR THEM-
IT'S NOT BASED ON THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN THAT THEY'RE SERVING AS
A STATE PHARMACY THIS OVERALL
FORMULA. AND SO IT IT IS. A
BIGGER PART OF FORMING THE BAND
DISTRICTS TO CHOOSE HOW TO
ALLOCATE WHAT THEYWANT TO FOCUS
ON ONE PARTICULAR SCHOOL SPREAD
OUT THROUGHOUT THE OLDER AREAS
WHERE THERE IS FLEXIBILITY FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO DECIDE- IT-
IT'S NOT BASED. THIS FINDING
ABOUT IS NOT BE. ON
PARTICIPATION. IT'S BASED ON-
THE T. THIRTY. CHARACTERS THE
COMMITMENT OF THE OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT- THE OTHER KEEPING THAT
I WOULD HIGHLIGHT IS THE
REQUIREMENT FOR SUMMER SO BUT IN
TERMS OF THE SCHOOL DAY THEY'RE
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT THERE WERE
THIRTY DEFINITELY BUT BY AND
LARGE. BUT DURING THE SCHOOL
YEAR REQUIREMENTS ARE VERY
SIMILAR TO YOU SINCE- SO WE
WOULD EXPECT THAT THERE WOULD
BE- SIMILAR LEVELS OF COVERAGE
DURING THAT AT THREE BUT- THE
BIG DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT YOU
KNOW PM ASUS IS THAT IT DOES
HAVE A SPECIFIC REQUIREMENT.
THAT THE PROGRAM BE OPEN. FOR
THIRTY DAYS DURING. DURING OUR
OR OUT OF SCHOOL WITH LIKELY
MISS SUMMER BUT ALSO COULD BE
DURING INTERSESSION. BREAK OUT
AND THAT THREE DURING THOSE
THREE DAYS TO BE MAYBE A BRAND
NEW NINE HOURS A DAY ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT AN IMPORTANT.
REQUIREMENT THAT DOESN'T EXIST
RIGHT NOW UNDER THE EXISTING
EXPANDED LEARNING PROGRAMS. MMHM
SO I THINK THAT'S THAT'S ONE OF
THE MAJOR DIFFERENCES HERE- I
THINK BOTH OF BRISTOL STOP HERE
IN TERMS OF THE SUMMARY TRYING
TO WALK THROUGH THE THREE
DIFFERENT PIECES I WOULD JUST
WHEN I GET A BIG PICTURE YOU'LL
YOU'LL HEAR MORE FROM THE
SPECIFIC PROGRAM EXPERTS IN THE
FIELD AFTER AFTER I FINISH
TALKING BUT I THINK THIS
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN FUNDING
CREATES OPPORTUNITY TO BETTER
SERVE THE NEEDS OF OUR CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES AND WE KNOW THAT
THIS PART OF THE CONVERSATION
TODAY WE HAVE HEARD SOME
DISTRICTS CONCERNED ABOUT. DATA
INCREASE IN AND BEAT UP THE
PROGRAM AND ENSURING THAT THEY
CAN- REFINED THE STAFFING TO
PROGRAM I HAVE OVER THE COMING
YEARS WE DO ALSO KNOW THAT THERE
ARE NUMBER OF COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE BEEN RUNNING
SIMILAR PROGRAMS THAT ARE
LOOKING FOR OPPORTUNITIES TO
PARTNER WITH THEM SO- HOPEFULLY
THE THOUGHT THIS OVER USE OVER
JUST KIND OF GETTING ON A LABEL
ON HOW THESE WORK ON SALISBURY
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS PEOPLE PROTECT. THANK
YOU EDGAR YES THE OVER YOU VERY
HELPFUL WE APPRECIATE THAT OUR
NEXT WE'LL BE HEARING FROM THE
SAMBAR DINO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION THE YMCA OF SAN DIEGO
AND BOTTLES NINOS WELCOME
EVERYONE THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE WE'LL GET BEGIN WITH MR
DURAN AND PROCEED IN ORDER OF
THE WITNESSES LISTED ON THE
AGENDA MR MURTADA RAM. PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU MADAM. INTAKE FOR ALLOWING
TO HAVE THIS PLAQUE. THANK YOU
AND YOUR- THAT ROLE OF BREAK OF
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS SO MY- IS
EXPANDED LEARNING AND I KNOW
THAT SENATOR LABOR'S BEEN A
CHAMPION FOR US WITH THIS
PROGRAM- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT.
THIS NEW FUNDING WITH YELLOW HAS
ALLOWED IS REALLY TOO. IT'S
GIVEN US AN OPPORTUNITY TO
INNOVATE WITH ALL STUDENTS WHO
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
AS YOU MENTIONED. THAT THAT THE
ASUS TWENTY FIRST WAS LIMITED ON
THE FUNDING RIGHT FOR STUDENT
PER DAY- AND SAW THAT WE HAD A
CERTAIN CAPITAL- WE COULD SERVE.
THIS NEW FINDING WITH YELLOW
PEAS ALLOWING US TO REALLY
EXPAND THE SERVICES TO THOSE FOR
INSTANCE IN OUR COUNTY. I HAVE
TWENTY DISTRICTS THAT HAVE
FUNDING TO ASUS TWENTY FIRST
THERE'S THIRTY TWO JUST SIX IN
OUR COUNTY SO NOW I HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL THIRTEEN DISTRICTS
THAT HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CREATE SOMETHING INNOVATIVE FOR
THE PANDEMIC. KIND OF PUT US IN
A TAILSPIN. BUT IT ALSO BROUGHT
EXPANDED LEARNING. TO THE
FOREFRONT INSTEAD OF BEING AN
AFTERTHOUGHT AFTER SCHOOL
BECAME- WE HAD AS- A CHOICE
CHAIR IN THE ROOM. IT MAY HAVE
BEEN A FOLDING CHAIR BUT NOW
WITH YELLOW KEY BECAUSE OF ALL
THE- IT OF ALL THE- OF WHAT THE
CAN DO. A THE DAY WHETHER IT BE
MORNING OR EVENING AND IN SUMMER
NOW WE ACTUALLY HAVE A SEAT AT
THE TABLE SO THANK YOU. FOR
ALLOWING THAT TO HAPPEN AND FOR
PROVIDING THOSE MUCH NEEDED
RESOURCES TO US. YOU ALSO
MENTION AFTER THAT AS FAR AS
BREEDING THE TWO PROGRAMS WITH
U. PGA ANY L. O. P. IT IS A
CHALLENGE INITIALLY BECAUSE IN
REALITY WHEN. WE'RE USED TO WITH
WORKING WITH ACES IN TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY. THE C. K. IT
WASN'T IN THE PICTURE SO T. K.
IS VERY ADM TO AFTER SCHOOL AS
WE KNOW IT- AND EVEN GENDER DOLE
WAS PART OF IT. WASN'T A BIG
FACTOR DIDN'T PLAY A BIG ROLE IN
A LOT OF OUR CURRENT PROGRAMS SO
NOW THE T. CASE COMING ON BOARD.
IT IS SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS TO-
AND YOU'LL HEAR FROM DOCTOR
SHONDA BIT. ABOUT HOW WE CAN
REALLY BREAK THOSE TWO PROGRAMS
TOGETHER SO IT'S GONNA TAKE A
LITTLE BIT OF TIME. TO REALLY
FIGURE OUT. KIND OF WHAT. IS
NEEDED NOT JUST AT THE SCHOOL
SITES BUT HOW WE CAN USE THE
COMMUNITY TO. MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
SO YOU MONEY'S NEW QUESTION
RIGHT THE WHOLE THING. BEING IN
THIS GAME FOR A BIT WE ALWAYS
HEARD WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH MONEY
TO. PROVIDE ENOUGH MORE SERVICES
AND YOU I'M SURE CENTER LABOR IN
MANY ON EDUCATION COMMITTEE
HEARD IT. THAT THERE WAS A
WAITING LIST OVER AND OVER WE
COULDN'T WE DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH
DOLLARS TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO
THOSE STUDENTS AGAIN. THANKS TO
THE C. L. O. P. FINDING U. K.
THAT WE HOPE TO RAISE IN THE
NEAR FUTURE. I'M AN INVITE- DR
SMITH WAS SHOT TO COME IN AND
SPEAK MORE TO. THE BRADY. WITH
U. PGA AND THEN I'LL COME BACK
ON. VERY GOOD THANK YOU WELCOME
DOCTOR SMITH ROUSSIN PLEASE
RECEIPT WHEN YOU'RE READY. THE
MORNING ON EVERYONE THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY IS FOR YOU
MY NAME IS DOCTOR KRISTIN THIS
MY FIRST JOHN AND I AM- HAPPY TO
REPRESENT SEVENTY NORTH TOWN. I
WOULD HAVE TO COME AND TALK
ABOUT UNIVERSAL PRE K. AND SO
WHILE WE ARE VERY EXCITED ABOUT-
HI NO THAT'S MY- EARLY CHILDHOOD
- IT DEFINITELY ASKING TOWNS AND
DISTRICTS HAVE LOTS OF
QUESTIONS- AND WE'RE SAYING THAT
WE ARE IN THE PLAN TO MAKE
THEIR- WHERE THEY'RE BEING ASKED
TO TAKE. THE PLANT ALONG WITH
YELLOW FRANCE AND WHAT WE ARE
REALLY ENCOURAGING THEM TO DO IT
TO THINK OF THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR SYSTEMS
INTEGRATION- THINK OF THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY START. OUR
WHOLE FAMILY WILL NOT CHILD
COMES THERE YOU'RE NOT JUST
THERE FOR THAT CHILD AS A WHOLE
FAMILY THAT CONNECTED TO IT AND
WE BELIEVE THAT BY REALLY
INTEGRATING NEW SYSTEMS THAT
WILL BETTER ALLOW DISTRICTS ARE
YOU DO THAT. IN A SCENE WITH
EFFORT BUT IT WILL TAKE SOME YOU
KNOW WORKING OUTSIDE THE BOXES
AND BREAKING SILOS WHICH-
EDUCATION HAS BEEN UNKNOWN TO DO
IN THE PAST SO WE'RE REALLY ARE
ALSO BEING DOING THAT AS YOU SEE
HERE TODAY- MY COLLEAGUE JOHN
AND I KNOW. I LEARNED HE'S
EXPANDED ONE WE HAVE BEEN-
BROUGHT TOGETHER UNDER A NEW
DIVISION HERE AT A SEMINAR COMES
IN THE SCHOOLS TO START REALLY
MODELING THAT WORK OUT HOW WE
CAN- REALLY- ONLINE SERVICES AND
REALLY BRING. US SYSTEMS
TOGETHER TO BETTER SERVE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES- THERE'S
DEFINITELY FROM THE DISTRICT-
CONCERN ABOUT- THE HEIGHTENED
ATTENTION ON FOUR YEAR OLD AND
REALLY WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
FOR OUR PEOPLE THAT BRING- IT IS
A SYSTEM WHICH ARE THE ONES. ARE
WE ARE THINKING ABOUT YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT HARD TO SELL I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
THINK ABOUT THAT AND ALSO THE
WORKFORCE CHALLENGES. THEIR
FOURTH.
IRAQ WE COMMITTING SUMMER YOU
KNOW PARENTS WORKING TOGETHER TO
STRATEGIZE INCLUDE USE A-
COLLECTIVE IMPACT APPROACH TO
SOLVING COMPLEX ISSUES- ANOTHER
THING- I SUPPORT THAT WE'RE
OFFERING TO OUR DISTRICTS AND
WE'RE CREATING R. I. C. K.
NETWORK SO THAT WE CAN COME FROM
BRAINSTORM TOGETHER AROUND
STRATEGIES FOR IMPLEMENTATION-
HAVE A LOCAL PLANNING COUNCIL
THAT IS. REALLY A COUNTY WIDE
STAKEHOLDER OPPORTUNITY FOR
EVERYONE IN THE COUNTY TO COME
TOGETHER AND LEARN AND SUPPORT
EACH OTHER AROUND EARLY LEARNING
ISSUES- AND THEN ACTING UNDER
UNDER MY EYES DEPARTMENT YOU
WILL- DO OFFICE HOURS SO THAT WE
CAN REALLY GET MY TEETH CLEANED.
OUT FOR THOSE DISTRICTS THAT.
ARE HAVING DIFFICULTY- AS JOHN'S
THEY DIDN'T HAPPEN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT ARE FOUND WHICH
MEANS THAT THIRTY THREE PLANTS
FOUR OAKLAND I NEED TO BE
CREATED- OUR GOAL IS TO REALLY
HELP AND SUPPORT THEM DISTRICTS
IN A WAY WHERE THE PLANS THAT
THEY SUBMIT WILL BE
COMPREHENSIVE- AND THAT THEY
WILL REALLY APPEAL NEEDS AND OF
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES- I AM
EXCITED- ABOUT. THE CHANGES
ALTHOUGH THEY MAY CREATE
CHALLENGES IT'S A VERY EXCITING
TIME FOR EARLY LEARNED WE
LEARNED DURING THE PANDEMIC- I'M
BIASED I ALWAYS KNEW THAT THIS
WAS VERY IMPORTANT- THOSE EARLY
YEARS BUT WE REALLY LEARN HOW
THE SYSTEM- SUPPORT THAT KIND OF
THING- AND REALLY IT'S REALLY
THE HEART. OF WHAT HE SAYS
MOVING SOUTH I'M VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THAT INVESTMENT I WANT TO
THANK SENATOR RAY BEFORE
CONTINUING YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
SUMMER NOT FOUND. AND FOR- JUST
REALLY CONTINUE TO SUPPORT IS
VERY IMPORTANT OUR TIME AND
CHILD IN THE FAMILY LIFE. THANK
YOU YOU'RE MOST WELCOME AND
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY
MR GRAHAM DID YOU SAY YOU WERE
GOING TO PICK UP AGAIN ARE WE
GOING TO GO YES OKAY. THANK YOU
SENATOR. SO THANK YOU. FOR
SHARING THAT- SHE IS. REALLY
THE- IN THE EARLY LEARNING- SO
COMBINE ISSUE SO. THANKS TO OUR
- TED ON A HUNDRED. WHICH IS
VERY. OF PUTTING THIS NEW
DEPARTMENT TOGETHER. WE'RE NOW.
TO ON WHAT IS AN STAKE IN WHAT
WE'RE- ON CALL. IN ONE OF THE
THINGS SHE MAY. WE ARE ASKED HOW
DO YOU IS IT EASY TO BREAK THESE
TWO PROGRAMS. IT ISN'T IN THE
BEGINNING BECAUSE WE'RE COMING
FROM TWO DIFFERENT. SETS OF
TREES- AND UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE
OF THE PANDEMIC AND I LOVE THAT.
CHRISTINA SAID PLAN TO MAKE.
BECAUSE OF THAT PEOPLE ARE HARD
TO FIND OUT TO STAFF ANDI WILL
WE SPEAK TO DISTRICTS AND WE'VE
BEEN DOING. A WORKSHOP FOR OUR
LARGE DISTRICTS ARE RURAL
DISTRICTS OR CHARTER SCHOOLS-
AND INDIVIDUALLY MEETING WITH
THEM TO SEE AND HEAR THEIR
CONCERNS. ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES JOHN. WE DON'T EVEN
HAVE TIME TO REALLY PLANNED FOR
THIS BECAUSE WE'RE WE'RE PRETTY
MUCH IN A SURVIVAL MODE OF
HAVING THE PEOPLE THAT COULD
WORK WITH THAT- HE'S LEARNING.
OR WORKING AFTER SCHOOL THERE
SOBBING THEY'RE HAVING TO FILL
IN AT CENTRE AND I'M THIS IS
ACROSS THE STATE I'M SURE. SO
ONE THAT'S BEEN ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES FOR THEM. THE
BLAST SCENE IS I TELL THEM IS
THAT YOU'VE GIVEN US THE
FLEXIBILITY. TO REALLY PLAN AND
HAVE TIME TO PLAN SO IT WASN'T
JUST SOMETHING THAT. YOU SENT TO
US AND SAID OKAY WE NEED A BY
SUCH AND SUCH DATE. AND THAT'S
THE BEAUTY OF WHAT THIS THIS
FUNDING IS ALLOWING US TO DO IS
REALLY. PLAN FOR THE FUTURE AND
AS YOU SAID TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THE COMMUNITY AND I KEEP
REMINDING. OUR DISTRICTS AS
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO REALLY DO
IS MEET WITH OUR PARENTS AND SEE
WHAT. WHAT OTHER CONFUSION MAYBE
BECAUSE THERE WAS CONFUSION WITH
YELLOW G. TWO YELLOW PEAS AND
SOME PEOPLE BLENDED THOSE TWO
GUYS WAIT A MINUTE THAT'S- IT'S
KIND OF SIMILAR BUT IT REALLY IS
AS- IN THEN NOW WE HAVE U. P.
SO. IT'S REALLY GETTING THE
MESSAGE OUT ABOUT. LET YOU BREAK
IT DOWN WHAT'S WHY AND WHO WERE
SERVING. IN HIS BUT LIKE
CHRISTINA SAID. THE SERVING FOUR
YEAR OLD IS A CHALLENGE BUT I'LL
LEAVE THAT TO HER HER- ARMANEN
HEARD KNOWLEDGE TO BE ABLE TO
REALLY WORK WITH ME. AND HOW WE
LOOK FORWARD TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH EXPANDED LEARNING. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE DO IS WE
DON'T JUST PREACH AND NOT
PRACTICE WHAT WE PREACH WE'VE
BEEN MODELING CAPS OF NINE HOURS
TOO SO DISTRICTS CAN SEE HOW THE
DAY LOOKS ESPECIALLY IN THOSE
INTERCESSION SUMMER PROGRAMS. IS
IT BECAUSE THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN A
CONCERN ARE YOU SURE WE HAVE TO
RUN A NINE HOUR PROGRAM. SO WE
CAN BREAK IT DOWN AND HOLDING
CAMPS WITH STUDENTS SO THEY
COULD SEE HOW THAT MAY LOOK IN
DURING SUMMER SESSION. GOOD IT'S
ALWAYS BEEN AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER. WHERE PEOPLE SAY WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO DO
THE THINGS THAT WE WANTED TO DO.
AND YOU KNOW THERE'S THAT OLD
SAYING NO MONEY NO MISSION BUT
THEY FORGET THE SECOND PART OF
THAT SCENE WHICH- THERE'S NO
MISSION. NO NEED FOR MONEY SO I
REMINDED DISTRICTS IS. THAT
REALLY LET'S HAVE A MISSION HAVE
YOUR MISSION AND YOUR GOAL OF
WHAT YOU PLAN TO DO. BEFORE NOW
YOU HAVE THE MONEY SO WE CAN
REALLY SERVE THE NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITY. I LIKE TO CALL IT
IT'S TEA TIME. IN TV BECAUSE-
IT'S GOING TO TAKE TO NASA. AND
WE WILL HAVE TRIALS AND
TRIBULATIONS DURING THIS TIME.
AND OF COURSE YES IT'S GOING TO
TAKE TIME TO GET THIS TO GET
THIS OFF THE GROUND AND REALLY
ENOUGH TO DESERVE TO DESIGN
PROGRAMS. THAT WE CAN SERVE THE
NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS AND TO
ALSO. SHAKE THE BUSHES TO SEE
WHO ELSE WE CAN BRING ON BOARD
THAT HAVE BEEN AND MISSING
DURING THIS PANDEMIC HERE. I
JUST WANT TO CLOSE WITH THIS IF
I MAY TWO DAYS. THE READ ACROSS
AMERICA AND BLUE I KNOW DOCTOR
RESIGNED AND I REDEEM TO SCHOOLS
LATER NOW I'M GONNA READ THAT
I'M READING TO THE STUDENTS A
MAGIC IS IN YOU. BY COLIN
HOSTING AND BROOKLYN TELL. THEN
IT SIMPLY SAYS IT'S HARD TO
LEAVE THE PAST BEHIND. JUST
REMEMBER THE MAGIC IS IN YOU. TO
CREATE A FUTURE OF BEAUTIFUL
MEMORIES AND I THINK THAT FITS
WITH THIS HEARING TODAY AND THAT
WE NEED TO KIND OF FORGET WHAT
WE LEARNED IN THE SENSE OF WHAT
WE THOUGHT PROGRAMMING WAS
BECAUSE LIKE I SAID AN AFTER
SCHOOL TEACHER HE DIDN'T EXIST.
SO OW WE REALLY NEED TO START
BUILDING ON THE FUTURE IF WE
REALLY WANT TO BUILD THIS
PIPELINE FROM ZERO TO TWELVE IN
ON AND BEYOND. IT WAS LASTING
ALL LEAVE ALL UP I SAID THIS
BEFORE BUT NOW I REALLY AM GOING
TO ADVOCATE FOR THE FUNDING IS
TEACHING A SIX SOMEHOW THAT WE
CAN FIND FUNDING TO REALLY BUILD
PROGRAMS. IN OUR MIDDLE HIGH
SCHOOL WHERE IS MUCH NEEDED- AS
YOU KNOW WE HAVE ASSETS AS FAR
AS THE FUN OF FEDERAL DOLLARS
THAT COME IN FROM THE STATE. BUT
IT'S NOT ENOUGH. B. ONE WORST
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO SAY WE'RE
BUILDING THIS PIPELINE. I THINK
WE NEED TO ALSO TRY AND INCLUDE
THEM. AS FAR AS MIDDLE AND HIGH
SCHOOL. YOUR TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR DURAND'S NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO COURTNEY BOTH SKI
I AM SO SORRY PARDON I GET THAT
RIGHT BUT YOU PLEASE CORRECT ME
LOVE YOUR FLAG IN THE BACKGROUND
AND PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
COURTNEY MULTI SKI- WITH THE
YMCA OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY IT'S AN
HONOR TO BE WITH YOU ALL TODAY.
I COME HERE AS AN ADVOCATE FOR
CHILDREN YOUTH AND THEIR
FAMILIES. I CONTRIBUTE TO THIS
WORK FOR OUR COLLECTIVE
ORGANIZING EFFORTS WITH THE
DIEGO. AND WITH THE WIRE AS A
DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY AND
STRATEGIC PARTNERSHIP. MY
DRIVING MOTIVATION COMES FROM
BEING A MOTHER OF A CURIOUS
SEVEN YEAR OLD NAMED MAX AND A
STRONG WILLED FOR YOUR OLD NAME
NORA. BOTH OF MY CHILDREN WERE
CARED FOR BY FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS. AS INFANTS AND
TODDLERS THEN ATTENDED QUALITY
FULL DAY YEAR ROUND PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS IN OUR NEIGHBORHOOD. MY
PARTNER AND I COULD NOT HAVE
CONTINUED WORKING WITHOUT THESE
INCREDIBLE EARLY EDUCATORS IN
OUR LIVES. THEY WILL FOREVER BE
OUR EXTENDED FAMILY. AS A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THE YMCA
OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY IS COMMITTED
TO WORKING ALONGSIDE OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS FOCUSED ON
CREATING EQUITABLE SYSTEMS
THROUGH AN APPROACH THAT
EMBRACES THE WHOLE CHILD. WHOLE
FAMILY AND WHOLE COMMUNITIES. AT
THE HEART OF OUR WORK WE HOLD
THESE NEEDS OF PARENTS
CAREGIVERS AND CHILDREN IN FULL
DAY FULL YEAR LEARNING CARE SO
THAT ALL MAY REACH. THEIR
FULLEST POTENTIAL WE DO A LOT TO
HELP OUR COMMUNITIES CHILDCARE
AND EXPANDED LEARNING NEEDS
THROUGH A VARIETY OF PROGRAMS.
THAT THE ELLIE- OFFICE MENTIONS
. MANY OF THESE HAVE LONG
WAITING LISTS YOU'RE READY GET
SET THESE PROGRAMS INCLUDE
EIGHTY FOUR EXPANDED LEARNING
PROGRAMS THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
PARTNERS INCLUDING ASUS AND
ASSETS CONTRACTS. WE ARE IN
DISCUSSION WITH PARTNERS FOR ELL
HE PROGRAMS THE RATES CONTINUE
TO BE A SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE.
FIFTY FIVE LICENSED CHILDCARE
CENTERS FOR AGES ZERO TO TWELVE
ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES AND CHILD
CARE CENTERS. TWENTY FIVE AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS FOCUSED ON CHILD
WELLNESS DAY CAMPS FOR AS MANY
AS NINE THOUSAND CHILDREN DAILY
PRE PANDEMIC AND OVER A DOZEN
LOCATIONS DURING SUMMER MONTHS.
MULTIPLE PROGRAMS TO CONNECT
CHILDREN YOUTH AND FAMILIES TO
MENTAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES. ADDITIONALLY WE ARE
SEEING YOUR COUNTY'S RESOURCE
AND REFERRAL AGENCY FOR CHILD
CARE. AND CHILD CARE ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT PROVIDER THIS PUTS US IN
DIRECT CONTACT WITH OVER FOUR
THOUSAND CHILDCARE PROVIDERS.
AND NEARLY FORTY THOUSAND
FAMILIES LAST FISCAL YEAR. THIS
COMBINED WORK HAS A TREMENDOUS
IMPACT WITHIN A SIGNIFICANT
ECOSYSTEM. IN THIS ECOSYSTEM
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF YMCA
STAFF PARENTS CARE GIVERS EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION PROFESSIONALS
AND SCHOOL DISTRICT PARTNERS.
ALL ARE NECESSARY TO ENSURE THE
YOUNGEST MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY. AGES ZERO TO TWELVE
ARE SURROUNDED BY SETTINGS WHERE
THEY CAN THRIVE AND BEGIN ON A
PATH TOWARD PROSPERITY. WE WILL
HEAR MANY THEMES TODAY ONE
IMPORTANTLY IS HE COMPASSION
AND DEDICATION OF OUR CHILD CARE
AND EXPANDED LEARNING WORK
FORCE. ANOTHER SADLY IS THE
STATE'S HISTORIC UNDERFUNDING
AND FRANKLY UNDERVALUING OF THIS
WORK FORCE RIGHT R. A RECENT
STUDY WITH THE CENTER OF THE
STUDY OF CHILD CARE EMPLOYMENT
DESCRIBES THESE EDUCATORS ASK
FOR GOTTEN ONES. IN THIS REPORT
A CALIFORNIA PROVIDER SHARED.
WE'RE CERTAINLY FRONTLINE
WORKERS WE ARE THE FORGOTTEN
ONES. AS WE ENGAGE WITH YOUNG
CHILDREN WE EXPOSE OURSELVES AND
OTHERS AND TAKE HEALTH RISKS
EVERY DAY WE DESERVE
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT AND BETTER PAY
AS AN INDUSTRY. IN SAN DIEGO
SEVENTY NINE CHILDCARE CENTRES
REMAIN CLOSED NEARLY 10% OF OUR
PRE PANDEMIC SUPPLY. A HUNDRED
AND FORTY EIGHT FAMILY CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS REMAIN CLOSED
NEARLY FIVE PERCENT. OF OUR PRE
PANDEMIC SUPPLY. AN ADDITIONAL
ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS REMAIN INACTIVE
MEANING SAN DIEGO STANDS TO LOSE
AN ADDITIONAL TWO THOUSAND. TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX LICENSED
CHILD CARE SLOTS. ALL THIS WHILE
PREPENDED MAKE LICENSE LOTS IN
SAN DIEGO WERE ONLY AVAILABLE
430% OF WORKING FAMILIES LESS
THAN 8% FOR INFANT AND TODDLER
SLOTS. THESE ARE SMALL
BUSINESSES OWNED BY THE
COMMUNITY FOR COMMUNITY MEMBERS
. WHEN WE LOSE THESE RESOURCES
WE ALL LOSE WE LOSE
ENTREPRENEURS AND EDUCATORS WHO
ARE LARGELY WOMEN OF COLOR WE
LOSE SAFE PLACES FOR CHILDREN
AND RESOURCE HUBS FOR FAMILIES.
WE LOSE THE HOPE OF GREATER
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY FOR OUR
REGION. SIMILARLY OUR EXPANDED
LEARNING TEAMS DID NOT SKIP A
BEAT DURING THE PANDEMIC.
BIDDING TO SUPPORT VIRTUALLY
THAN IN PERSON PRIOR TO SCHOOLS
BEING OPEN. WITH SUPPORT FROM
OUR COUNTY AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS
SUMMER PROGRAM SERVES STUDENTS
IN PERSON IN TWENTY TWENTY. AND
THIS AT A PACE FOR REOPENING
PLANS THAT MUNICIPALITIES AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ADOPTED IN
LATER MONTHS. OUR TEAMS TO GREAT
RISK FOR THEMSELVES AND FOR
THEIR FAMILIES. WHY DID THEY DO
IT. WHEN ASKED TO SITE
SUPERVISOR SHARE WE KNEW OUR
PRINCIPAL PARENTS AND OF COURSE
KIDS NEEDED US. OUR STUDENTS
WERE AT HOME SOME ON THEIR OWN.
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS WHO DIED OF
COVE IT AND WE SAW THE LIGHT
LEAVING THEIR EYES. WE'RE
CONTINUALLY GRATEFUL FOR THE
IMPORTANT WORK HAPPENING WITH
PARTNERS AT CVG AND DSS.
ADMINISTERING THESE RESOURCES TO
THE COMMUNITY IS NO EASY TASK
AND COLLABORATION HAS BEEN KEY
TO ENSURE. THOSE WITH THE
GREATEST NEEDS ARE EFFICIENTLY
RECEIVING RESOURCES WITH THIS
SOME OF WHAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED
INCLUDES. DELAYED CONTRACTS THE
WAY FUNDING UNREALISTIC
TIMELINES. AND UNCOMPENSATED
EXPECTATIONS. USER ADDED BURDENS
ON OUR ADMINISTRATIVE EFFORTS
WHICH ARE ALREADY INCREDIBLY
FATIGUED BY THE DAY TO DAY
OPERATIONS OF THE IMPORTANT WORK
HAPPENING INCLUDING THE
CONTINUED CHALLENGE. OF HIRING.
OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS ALSO
EXPERIENCE LIMITED RESOURCES DUE
TO HISTORIC UNDERFUNDING UNJUST
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS. AND
CUMBERSOME SYSTEMS THEY MUST
NAVIGATE ALL OF PARENTING AND
OFTEN WORKING FULL TIME. AS
CALIFORNIA MOVES TO IMPLEMENT
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN ACROSS
THE STATE IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
POLICY MAKERS AND OUR DISTRICTS
DESIGNED TO KEEP PROGRAMS THEY
CONSIDER REFLECT THE DIVERSE
NEEDS AND PERSPECTIVES MANY
STAKEHOLDERS WHICH MAKE UP THE
LARGER ECOSYSTEM OF THE
UNIVERSAL PRE KINDERGARTEN
SYSTEM WE SEE THE SCOPE OF WORK
AS A PROGRAM ADMINISTRATOR.
THERE ARE MANY COMPLEXITIES AND
IMPLICATIONS TO CONSIDER. IT IS
OKAY TO SLOW THIS DOWN AND YOUR
CHILDREN FAMILIES AND ALL
EDUCATORS JUSTICE IN CALIFORNIA
. RECENTLY WE BROUGHT OUR TEAMS
TOGETHER TO CREATE AN IMPORTANT
RESOURCE FOR STATE INCLUSIVE
FRAMEWORK FOR DESIGNING AND
IMPLEMENTING PRE KINDERGARTEN IN
CALIFORNIA IS A DECISION MAKING
MODEL FOR SCHOOL DISTRICT'S
POLICY MAKERS AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS TO LOOK TOO AS THEY
CREATE SHE K PROGRAMS THAT
BENEFIT AND UPLIFT THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY. THROUGH A WHOLE CHILD
WHOLE FMILY WILL COMMUNITY
APPROACH THIS FRAMEWORK EXPLORES
THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES EXPANDED LEARNING
PROVIDERS CHILDCARE PROVIDERS
SCHOOLS AND EDUCATORS AND OFFERS
A SET OF RECOMMENDATIONS
DESIGNED TO MEET. EACH MEETING.
THIS FRAMEWORK IS INCLUDED IN
YOUR PACKAGE TODAY. THEMES OF
THIS FRAMEWORK INCLUDE CONTINUED
AWARENESS RAISING ACROSS OUR
SECTORS SHARED DECISION MAKING
AUTHENTIC ENGAGEMENT AND
PARTNERSHIPS FOR HOLISTIC
SUPPORT AND FULL DAY
PROGRAMMING. AND IMPORTANTLY A
PARENT'S ABILITY TO CHOOSE WHAT
IS BEST FOR THEIR FAMILY. THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TODAY AND FOR SHARING THE BELIEF
THAT WHEN WE CHOOSE TO PURSUE A
BETTER TOMORROW TOGETHER. WE CAN
CREATE A CALIFORNIA WHERE
YOUNGEST LEARNERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES REACH RESILIENCE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISS POLSKI YOUR
COMMENTS WERE ABSOLUTELY SPOT ON
AND WE APPRECIATE EVERYTHING
THAT YOU WERE DOING THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE MOVE TO
MISS ANGELA CAPONE WHEN YOU'RE
READY MISS COMPOUND PLEASE
PROCEED.
I THINK YOU'RE ON MUTE. OKAY
STILL HARASSED ALL OF US WELCOME
HI IT'S NOT. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIRMAN- AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
CARLOS NINO'S WHOSE EARLY
CHILDHOOD PROGRAM- BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY TO SHARE SOME OF THE
STRUGGLES ON WE APPRECIATE THE
DIRECTION THAT THE STATE IS
MOVING AND REALLY SHINING THE
LIGHT ON THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
EARLY YEARS. CURRENTLY CARLOS
NINOS OPERATES SEVEN EARLY
CHILDHOOD PROGRAMS IN THE
GREATER LOS ANGELES AREA- AND
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT'S
DECEPTIVE ABOUT SAYING SEVEN. ON
IT SOUNDS EASY WE HAVE PROGRAMS
THAT SERVE CHILDREN TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY DAYS A YEAR. AND WE
SERVE THEM TEN AND A HALF HOURS
A DAY WE ARE PROGRAMMED SETS ARE
OPEN TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY DAYS
TWO YEARS SERVING CHILDREN
SEVEN. OR EIGHT OR NINE HOURS A
DAY WE HAVE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
OFTEN OPEN A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE DAYS A YEAR. ON SERVING
CHILDREN SIX HOURS A DAY SO WHAT
I WANT YOU TO UNDERSTAND IS THAT
THE TASK AT HAND IS JUST AS YOU
SAID AT THE BEGINNING OF THIS
MEETING. TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
FAMILY NEEDS ARE DIFFERENT AND
DIVERSE AND IT IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY WE BELIEVE OF
PROGRAMS TO MEET THOSE NEEDS AND
MEET THOSE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
WHERE THEY ARE IN THE MOST
RESPONSIVE WAY. THAT DOES NOT
COME WITHOUT THE CHALLENGE. ON
WE OPERATE OUR PROGRAMS BY
BLENDING FUNDING WE PROVIDE WE
USE HEAD START DOLLARS. PLUS C.
S. P. P. DOLLARS TO SERVE OUR
PRESCHOOLERS THREE TO FIVE AND
WE USE EARLY HEAD START DOLLARS
PLUS THE CTR DOLLARS TO SERVE
OUR INFANTS AND TODDLERS. ON I
WANT TO BE REALLY CLEAR THAT WE
ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BRAID FUNDING. BUT IT DOES
NOT COME WITHOUT ITS CHALLENGES
OUR FAMILIES AND OUR PROVIDER
MUST ENSURE THAT FAMILIES MEET
THE CRITERIA OF BOTH FUNDING
SOURCES. AND THOSE FUNDING
SOURCES ARE NOT ALWAYS
CONSISTENT SO WHILE A CHILD
FAMILY MAY QUALIFY FOR C. S. P.
P. SERVICES THEY DO NOT QUALIFY
FOR HEAD START SERVICES
POTENTIALLY. AND THAT MEANS THAT
IF WE'VE GRADED FUNDING IN A
CLASSROOM THAT FAMILY CANNOT
PARTICIPATE IN THAT CLASSROOM.
SO WE TURN OURSELVES INTO
PRETZELS TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
CLASSROOMS THAT HAVE SINGULAR
FUNDING SO THAT WE CAN SERVE AS
MANY FAMILIES AS POSSIBLE. BASED
ON THEIR NEEDS- ALSO JUST TO BE
CLEAR ON THE FUNDING WE HAVE
RECEIVED INCREASES WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR THE INCREASES IN
THOSE FUNDING BUT NEITHER HEAD
START FUNDING NOR. C. S. P. P.
OR C. C. T. R. FUNDING PROVIDED
ALL THE FUNDS THAT WE NEED TO-
TO RUN A PROGRAM WE RUN AT A
DEFICIT AND WE ARE GRATEFUL TO
OUR LISTENING AS HIS DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. ON AND
PHILANTHROPISTS WHO ARE THERE TO
SUPPORT US IN THE IMPORTANCE OF
WORK THAT WE DO- I WANT TO
REALLY- HEARKEN BACK TO.
COURTNEY'S WORDS WHERE SHE
ACKNOWLEDGE THE ROLE OF EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATORS IN THE LIVES
OF FAMILIES I. SHEIK HEARING
THOSE WORDS AND I KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS ON A DAY TO DAY
BASIS TO HAVE KNOWLEDGE THAT WE
JOINED THE FAMILY. IN HELPING
PARENTS TO ENSURE THAT THEIR
CHILDREN AND THEIR FAMILIES
THRIVE IN AN ENVIRONMENT THAT IS
DIFFICULT FOR THEM AND THAT IS
OUR GOAL. JUST SO THAT YOU
REALIZE 49% OF OUR FAMILIES ARE
AT THE POVERTY LEVEL OR BELOW.
31% OF OUR FAMILIES NOW SELF
IDENTIFY AS HOMELESS. 57% OF OUR
FAMILIES ARE SPANISH SPEAKERS.
ON RIGHT NOW EARLY ADD FACES A
MAJOR CRISIS AND THAT IS A
CRISIS OF TEACHERS QUALIFIED
TEACHERS FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
PL AND VERY LONG HISTORY. WE
HAVE CHILDREN ON THE WAITING
LIST NOT BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
OPENINGS FOR CHILDREN BUT
BECAUSE WE DO NOT HAVE TEACHERS
TO PUT IN CLASSROOMS THIS HAS
BECOME A CRISIS EARLY EDUCATION
. PART OF THE CRISIS IS HYPE.
THAT PREPARES PEOPLE TO JOIN A
PROFESSION THAT IS THE CENTRAL
IMPORTANCE IN NOT ONLY THE LIVES
OF CHILDREN AND FAMILIES BUT IN
PREPARING CHILDREN FOR LIFE AND
FOR EACH SUCCESSIVE EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITY- IN TERMS OF THE
CHANGING COMPLEXION OF LOS
ANGELES MORE AND MORE OF OUR
FAMILIES ARE WORKING. SO WE HAVE
TURNED ONE OR MORE OF OUR
CLASSROOMS INTO FULL DAY
CLASSROOMS TO MEET FAMILY NEEDS.
BUT THAT MEANS IN A ROOM THAT I
COULD HAVE SERVED FIFTEEN
CHILDREN IN THE MORNING AND
FIFTEEN CHILDREN IN THE
AFTERNOON THAT'S SERVING THIRTY
FAMILIES I CAN NOW ONLY SERVE
FIFTEEN FAMILIES. AND QUITE
HONESTLY- IN EARLY AND WE HAVE A
SAYING IT'S CALLED THE DEARTH OF
EARTH. IN LOS ANGELES THAT IT IS
VERY DIFFICULT TO FIND
FACILITIES TO GROW OUR PROGRAMS
TO MEET THE GROWING NEEDS OF
FAMILIES- AND WHEN WE FIND
FACILITIES THAT RENTS. WE HAVE A
FACILITY WHERE THE RENT IS
UPWARDS OF A MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR THIS FAR EXCEEDS THE
FUNDING. FOR PRESCHOOL PROGRAM.
I ELLEN IS APPS COMMITTED TO
FINDING SOLUTIONS TO THE
STRUGGLES THAT OUR FAMILIES AND
OUR CHILDREN ENCOUNTER- AND WE
ARE PROUD TO HAVE. AS MANY
OPTIONS AS WE HAVE AND WE ARE
PLEASED TO PARTNER WITH STATE
PROGRAMS TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THOSE OPTIONS- WE JOIN YOU IN
KEEPING AN EYE ON THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE EARLY YEARS AND THIS WORK
WITH CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISS CAPONE WE ARE NOW GOING TO
MOVE TO CECILIA HERNANDEZ
CECILIA BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
. GOOD MORNING MY NAME SYSTEM
NATIONAL THIS DIRECTOR OF
EXTENDED LEARNING AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING VITAL SENONES ALSO
MEANT TO START OFF WITH GIVING
YOU A LITTLE BIT OVERVIEW. I
DON'T KNOW YES BACKGROUND WE
WERE FOUNDED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
AND PLN HAS BEEN SERVING THE
COMMUNITY OF DOWNTOWN LOS
ANGELESFOR ABOUT FORTY YEARS
NOW. AND WE SERVE AND SUPPORT
ABOUT TEN THOUSAND CHILDREN
YOUTH AND FAMILIES A YEAR AND
THAT IS THROUGH OUR DIFFERENT-
PROGRAMS AND DEPARTMENTS THAT WE
HAVE SUCH AS EARLY EDUCATION AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS AFTER SCHOOL
YOUTH WORKSOURCE. MENTAL HEALTH
THE WRAPAROUND SERVICES IN AN
APPARENT LEADERSHIP ENGAGEMENT
SO TO GIVE YOU A QUICK OVERVIEW
OF THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE
FAMILIES WE SERVE. ABOUT 90%
LATINO AND THEIR- YEARLY INCOME
IS TECHNICALLY RIGHT AT ABOUT
FIFTEEN THOUSAND A YEAR. BUT
APPROXIMATELY MORE THAN 50% OF
OUR STUDENTS HAVE OUR PARENTS
SORRY DO NOT HAVE A COLLEGE
DEGREE. SO TODAY YOU HEARD A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT OUR EARLY
EDUCATION PROGRAM AND NEXT I
WILL BE SPEAKING ABOUT OUR AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS I WANT TO SHARE
WITH YOU ALL- THREE HIGHLIGHTS
THAT DIFFERENCE- FROM OTHER
PROGRAMS WITHIN THE AFTER SCHOOL
FIELD. AND OUR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMMING OR THREE CHARTER
SCHOOLS IS DESIGNED TO SERVE OUR
STUDENTS WITH A VERY SAFE AND
ENRICHING ENVIRONMENT
CONSIDERING WE ARE IN THE SKID
ROW AREA OF DOWNTOWN LOS
ANGELES. AND WE INTEGRATE
VARIOUS COMPONENTS ON OUR DAILY-
SCHEDULE SUCH AS ACADEMIC.
ACTIVITIES IN THE AREAS OF STEM
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING ARTS
AND WE HAVE VARIOUS
COLLABORATIVE PARTNERSHIPS THAT
WE WORK WITH SO IN ORDER TO MAKE
ALL THIS POSSIBLE WE REALLY HAVE
TO CONSIDER ALL OF THE FUNDING
SOURCES THAT WE WORK WITH. SUCH
AS THEIR. TWENTY FIRST CENTURY.
R. A. AND R. C. C. T. WHICH IS A
GREAT SURELY OUR EARLY AT TWO
KEY UP. WHICH MEANS THAT. OUR TO
OUR OUR REACH. ARE LIKE. AFTER
SCHOOL. TO COMMUNITY CAROL. AND
THROUGH THE USE OF DIFFERENT
FUNDING SOURCES WERE ABLE TO
PROVIDE- PROGRAMMING TO ALMOST
85% OF OUR STUDENTS ENROLLED IN
OUR CHARTER SCHOOLS. I DON'T
WANT TO MENTION A PARTICULAR
HIGHLIGHT. IN OUR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS IS THAT ALL OF OUR
STAFF ARE EMPLOYED BY BUT IT WAS
THE YOUNG SWITCH LEXUS OPERATE
DIFFERENTLY AND NOT AS A
CONTRACTOR. I'D REALLY SUPPORTS
THE COOPERATION AND INTEGRATION
WITH THE SCHOOL DAY SO WE'RE
REALLY ABLE TO CONNECT AND HELP
OUR CHILDREN. AND FAMILIES IN
VARIOUS DIFFERENT LEVELS AS WE
ARE ALL ONE AND WE PRIDE IN THE
INTEGRATED SERVICES MODEL ALSO
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO LINK OUR FAMILIES TO OTHER
SERVICES SUCH AS- YOU KNOW THE
NEED OF MENTAL HEALTH OR WANTS
HER. STUDENTS ARE A LITTLE BIT
OLDER THEY JOINED THE YOUTH
WORKS DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT- SO
THAT REALLY BRINGS US INTO BEING
ABLE TO SUPPORT THE WHOLE
FAMILY. ONE OF OUR MAJOR
HIGHLIGHTS I WOULD SAY WITHIN
OUR DEPARTMENT OF AFTER SCHOOL
IS THAT INTERCESSION FOR THE
PROGRAMS. AND THAT IS OUR MAN R.
SORRY OURS SUMMER. AND OUR
SPRING AND FALL PROGRAMS THAT WE
OFFER IT. THE GRAND IT'S REALLY
GOING TO. US REALLY BECOME TO A
DAY. AS I MENTIONED SCHOOLS ARE.
YOU KNOW COMMUTER SCHOOLS AND IN
THE DOWNTOWN AREA SO MANY OF OUR
FAMILIES ACTUALLY FOR TWO OUT OF
THREE. LIVE OUTSIDE OF THAT THE
COMMUNITY SO THIS REALLY HELPS
US AND MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
ABLE TO PROVIDE. MORE DAYS. OF
PROGRAMMING FOR OUR STUDENTS.
CURRENTLY DURING THE SUMMER AND
THE SPRING BREAK. AND THE BALL
PROGRAM WE OFFER A PRETTY
EXTENSIVE DAY BUT WITH THE
SUPPORT I WOULD DEFINITELY LET
US INCREASE OUR NUMBERS AS WE
STILL HAVE SOME WEIGHTLESS. I
WAS SPECIAL HIGHLIGHT OF ALL
THOSE PROGRAMS IS THAT WE REALLY
FOCUS ON COMMUNITY EXPLORATION.
DURING THE INTERSESSION PROGRAMS
WHERE WE REALLY WANT TO TAKE THE
KIDS OUTSIDE OF THE COMMUNITY
HAVE THEM EXPLORE AND LEARN. NEW
PLACES THAT HONESTLY IF IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN FOR OUR PROGRAMS THEY
WOULDN'T PROBABLY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO ATTEND ALL THOSE
PLACES. BUT ALONG WITH
HIGHLIGHTS AND GOOD THINGS IN
OUR PROGRAMS ALSO ROADBLOCKS.
AND ONE OF THE BIG ONES IS
WEIGHTLESS. YOU KNOW I DOLLARS
ONLY SO GO STRAIGHT IN. YOU KNOW
WAY SO WE STILL HAVE. QUITE A
FEW NUMBER OF STUDENTS ON THE
WAITLIST AS YOU KNOW THE GRASS
ONLY ALLOW US TO SERVE X. AMOUNT
OF STUDENTS. ANOTHER BIRD AND
THAT HURTS OUR BUDGET IS THE
COST OF FACILITIES AND
MAINTENANCE OUR BUDGETS ARE
ALREADY SO TIGHT BUT YOU KNOW
THESE ARE EXPENSES THAT. YOU
KNOW ARE NEEDED FRENCH STATE
TODAY PROGRAMMING. AND AS OTHERS
HAVE MENTIONED THE WORK FORCE
ISSUES AND PAY IS CRITICAL- WE
TEND TO BE VERY SHORT STAFFED
AND THAT. THIS TIME- AND WE ALSO
NEED TO STAY COMPETITIVE WITH
SALARIES YOU KNOW S. RECRUITMENT
HAS ALSO BEEN A HUGE PROBLEM
ACROSS THE FIELD I SEE HERE IN
EARLY AND IT IS THE SAME FOR.
OUR AFTER SCHOOL PROVIDERS. SO
THE OTHER CRUCIAL THING IS THAT
ABILITY TO HAVE STAFF- COVERED
DIFFERENT. MASSES OR PLACES.
BECAUSE OF THE GRANT
REQUIREMENTS LIKE I MENTIONED WE
HAVE DIFFERENT GRANTS SO THEY
HAVE DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS AND
STAFFING- AND LASTLY. IN ORDER
TO MAKE ALL THIS POSSIBLE WE
DEPEND HIGHLY ON OUR EXTERNAL
AFFAIRS TEAMS TO HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO. FIND ADDITIONAL
FUNDING SO THAT WE'RE ABLE TO.
HAVE MORE STUDENTS IN OUR
PROGRAMS OR DOES INTERCESSION
SUMMER DAYS AND- LIKE I
MENTIONED BEFORE. ANY OTHER
EXTRA FUNDING WOULD DEFINITELY
HELP WAS REALLY HAPPY MORE KIDS
IN OUR PROGRAM AS IT IS. REALLY
SAD AND DIFFICULT TO TURN AWAY
STUDENTS BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH FUNDING TO PROVIDE THE
PROGRAM FOR EVERYONE- FOR I AND
I JUST WANNA SAY. THREE
FUNDAMENTAL SUPPORT AND
PARTNERSHIP SENATOR DOLE OUT SO
THANK YOU FOR THE SUPPORT- THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME. AND THIS
IS A GOOD UP I LOVE YES AFTER
PROGRAM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MISS. WE'RE NOW GOING TO
MOVE ON OUR FOR OUR NEXT PANEL
BUT THANK YOU SO MUCH TO OUR
FIRST PANELIST. AND IF I CAN ASK
YOU TO STAY ON SO THAT WE MIGHT
BE ABLE TO GO TO YOU FOR
QUESTIONS AT THE END. OUR NEXT
OUR PANEL INCLUDES CHILD ACTION
AND A PARENT WE WELCOME BOTH OF
YOU MR GARCIA WE WILL START WITH
YOU PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR.
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT FURTHER.
ALREADY FROM THE PRESENTERS
ABOUT SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
WITH THE SYSTEMS OF CARE. THAT
ARE AVAILABLE FOR OUR FAMILIES.
I MYSELF WORK AT A RESOURCE AND
REFERRAL. PROGRAM HERE. IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND ONE. FOR
BRING DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES OF
THE STRUGGLES AND CHALLENGES
THEY FACE. AS THEY SEEK
AFFORDABLE QUALITY CARE FOR
THEMSELVES. AS A RESOURCE AND
REFERRAL AGENCY WE ARE OFTEN THE
FIRST POINT OF CONTACT FOR
FAMILIES LOOKING FOR. THIS
PARTICULAR CARE TO SERVE YOUR
NEEDS. AS THEY STRUGGLE TO FIND
THAT SHARE. WHEN THE FIRST
COMPONENTS IS THE HOURS OF CARE
THAT THEY NEED. IN THE DAYS OF
CARE THAT THING. THIS OFTEN
BECOMES A STRUGGLE WITH THE
MATCHING THOSE HOURS AND DAYS.
THAT A FAMILY MIGHT NEED CARE
WITH THE HOURS AND DAYS YOUR
ABILITY FOR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS. MORE RECENTLY OF
COURSE THESE BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC. PROVIDERS HAVE
STRUGGLED WITH THE HOURS OF
OPERATION. SOME OF THEM HAVING
TO CLOSE TEMPORARILY SOME
CLOSING. DOWN LONGER TERM. WAS
FAMILIES WORK THROUGH THAT AND
FINDING THE RIGHT MATCH FOR
THEMSELVES. THERE ARE. ALWAYS
CHALLENGES WITH THE-
TRANSPORTATION OR- SOME OF THE
OTHER FAMILY NEEDS THAT COME UP
BECAUSE OF LIMITED. ECONOMIC
ACCESS. IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT A- AS A RESOURCE
AND REFERRAL. MATERNITY PROGRAM
HERE IN SACRAMENTO THAT DO HAVE
RESOURCES WILL. RETURN APPEARED
PROGRAMS. THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
IN EVERY COUNTY AND THOSE
STORIES WITHIN THOSE COUNTIES.
ARE GOING TO DEPEND ON. FITS IN
THE- COMMUNITY. BUT GENERALLY
SPEAKING ALL FAMILIES FACED THIS
ISSUE. FINDING HERE. DURING THE
HOURS AND DAYS. THERE NEEDS. AND
WHO. OFFER THEM SIR. OF I EVEN
DAYS THE LATE NEXT. SECOND THAT
WE WOULD WE HAVE FAMILIES COME
WITH THAT MEANS HIS BOOK THE OF
YOUR CHILDREN- WE SEE IN DASH.
THE MUCH OF REQUEST THAT COME TO
US MORE QUALITY CARE. R. FOR HIM
LEARNERS THEREFORE THE EFFECTIVE
TODDLER POPULATION WITH LITTLE
MORE THAN. 70% OFTEN. CALL FROM
LOOKING FOR IN THE LEARNERS AND
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE CARE THAT'S
AVAILABLE WITHIN THE LICENSE KEY
. IT'S ONLY LOCALLY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO ONLY ABOUT 25230% OF
THE LICENSE SPACES ARE
AVAILABLE. HERE THIS MEANS A
MAJORITY CARE FOR OUR YOUNGEST
LEARNERS IS HAPPENING IN THE
FAMILY CHILD CARE HOME PROVIDER
COMMUNITY AND THE FAMILY AND YOU
WERE. WE SAW BEEN SOME RECENT
DATA FROM. TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
TO TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE-
13% DECREASE IN THINK HERE IN
OUR CENTER POPULATION THAT MEANS
THERE'S NEED FOR INCREASED
INFANT CARE IN OUR FAMILY CHILD
. AND FAMILY FRIEND AND NEIGHBOR
HERE. AND ANOTHER ISSUE THAT
AMNESTY SAYS THEY'RE SEEKING NOT
CARE TO MEET THEIR NEEDS HIS
LANGUAGE HERE IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY WE HAVE ABOUT SIXTY. 71%
OF OUR LICENSE IN OUR PROGRAMS
SPEAKING ENGLISH ONLY- THIS CAN
BE A CHALLENGE IN A VERY-
FAMILIES. WHO MAYBE AREN'T QUITE
COMFORTABLE OR PERHAPS MORE
PEOPLE WORKING IN THE READING
SPEAKING- FAMILY WAS LOOKING FOR
SERVICES PROVIDED. THANK YOU.
THE CHALLENGE HERE IS THIS THIS
IS OFTEN EXTENDS BEYOND
INTERPRETATION SERVICES AND-
INCLUDES THE. CULTURAL
UNDERSTAND. SO WE NEED FAMILIES
STRUGGLE WITH THE THANK YOU WHAT
THAT MIGHT LOOK LIKE YEAH. THE
CARE HOME WHERE THIS COMES WE
THE- AND PROVIDERS AND NOW WHO
ARE LOOKING FOR HEREWHAT WE SEE
MORE. IS THIS NEED FROM
PROVIDERS FIND BALANCE. FOR
THEMSELVES BOTH THEIR WORK LIFE
- AS ADULTS WHO ARE COMMITTED
AND CARING FOR YOUNG CHILDREN-
ALSO FAMILIES OF THEIR OWN THAT
ARE. SO THAT RIGHT NOW WILL
OFFER. AN OFFER THE COMMITMENTS
THEY MADE TO FAMILIES TO CARE
FOR HIS FAMILY BUT ALSO KEEP
THEIR OWN THEM IN MIND. THE
OTHER UP. IS THAT WE SEE COME UP
FOR PROVIDERS IS WITH THEIR OWN
BUSINESS OPERATIONS THESE ARE
SMALL BUSINESSES THEY DO HAVE A
REVENUE SOURCE THAT REVENUE
SOURCES OFTEN- DATE CHILDREN
ENROLLED IN YOUR PROGRAM- SO
FINDING A WAY. TO CONTINUE BEING
AVAILABLE BASED ON A FAMILY
NEEDS- THEM IF IT'S A- FAMILY
WITH OUR OUR CARE NONTRADITIONAL
HOURS HERE WE CAN HEAR EACH
YEAR- IN EVEN THOSE FAMILIES
THAT ACCESS SOME OF THE MORE
TRADITIONAL PROGRAMS MODELS.
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS OR
SPENDING LEARNING PROGRAMS THAT
WOULD PROVE THAT SOME ARE
CALLING ARE WORKING HARD TO
OFFER THOSE SAME FAMILIES ALSO
HAVE NEEDS THAT EXTEND BEYOND.
THAT TRADITIONAL HOURS HERE MANY
OF THEM ARE LYING ON OTHER
FAMILY MEMBERS OTHER SYSTEMS OR
GET THEIR CHILDREN TO BRAHMS
PROGRAMS OFTEN THERE BE. SCHOOL
OR WORK- BILLS HOURS EXTEND
BEYOND TRADITIONAL OUR
PROGRAMMER EVEN SOME OF THE
TRANSPORTATION. CHALLENGES THAT
. MMHM FACE. SO WHAT WE UNDER.
HEARING FROM THEM. THE
CHALLENGES OCCUR THE BOARD
FINDING HERE THAT NEEDS THEIR
NEEDS WHILE TO BUILD RELATIONS
WITH PROVIDER. ALSO NEEDS THAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO BALANCE AND
MATCH THOSE NEEDS TO OUR FAMILY
OF COURSE THE MOST RECENT
PANDEMIC CREATES ISSUES NEW
AGENTS FOR PROVIDERS AND
FAMILIES. WITH SOME OF THE
HYBRID MODELS OF WORK WHEN THE
REMOTE WORKING POSSIBILITIES
WHERE NOW THE CHILDREN WHO WERE
ONCE IN HERE. FOR LONGER PERIODS
OF TIME PERHAPS TO DROP IN
STATUS IS NEEDED FROM FIVE PM TO
SCHEDULE TO A TWO DAY A WEEK
SCHEDULE SO CERTAINLY A LOT OF
CHALLENGES FACING FAMILIES AND A
LOT OF CHALLENGES FACING
PROVIDERS. THAT THEY STRUGGLE TO
KEEP THEIR DOORS OPEN AND THE
NEEDS OF. THE SAME FAMILY. WHAT
WE KNOW IS- FAMILIES ARE MAKING
WORK AND THESE ARE. RESILIENT
THE A. ARE DOING THE BEST THEY
CAN. EVEN IN THE FACE OF THESE
CHALLENGES NO WE ALSO RECOGNIZES
THE STILL NEED THE HARD WORK OF.
PARTNERS SPEAKERS BEFORE ME AND
EVERYONE HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE THE BEST. POSSIBLE CARE
OPTIONS FOR THEIR YOUNG CHILDREN
AND MURDERS OF OUR- MMHM. SO
WITH THAT I CONCLUDE MY COMMENTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE THAT MR
GARCIA NEVER GONNA MOVE TO LILY
MARQUEZ ONE OF OUR PARENTS MS
MARQUEZ POPE PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. GOOD MORNING HELLO
MY NAME IS LI MY KIDS I AM A
LEADER WITH PARENT VOICES WITH
EXPENSIVE COACH AFTER. MOST
IMPORTANTLY ON THE
CHARACTERISTICS YOU'LL BE
JEREMIAH THAT IS IN THE FIRST
GRADE AND A FIVE YEAR OLD. THAT
MEANS ME A FELLOW WENT TO
COMPETE IN THE GARDEN. AND WE
LIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA
. I WANT TO SPEAK TODAY ABOUT MY
EXPERIENCE HAVING A CHILD IN THE
OPEN AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS AS
WELL AS A CHILD ENROLLED. IN A
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM. WHEN MY SON
STARTED ELEMENTARY. SCHOOL IN
PERSON WITH WITH A COUPLE OF
WEEKS HE HAD BEEN- DOING VIRTUAL
OFFENDER INTO. KINDERGARTEN YEAR
PRETTY MUCH THE FIRST EIGHT
MONTHS OF IT- I REALIZED THAT MY
SON NEEDED A LOT OF HELP AND
ASSISTANCE. I CAN AFFORD
CHILDCARE WHEN THEY WERE SMALLER
SO I QUIT MY JOB AND I MADE
SEVERAL SACRIFICES TO STAY WITH
THEM UNTIL THEY WERE ABLE TO GO
TO SCHOOL. SO WHEN MY KIDS ARE
LOOKING TO BUY. REALIZED THAT HE
WAS AT A HUGE DISADVANTAGE
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T HAVE ANY EARLY
EDUCATION SETTING A BACKGROUND.
SO IT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME
. LAST YEAR TO FIND AN AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAM FOR HIM HE HAS AN
I. P. AND I LOOK AT THE TV EVEN
WORKING FINE AS HE STRUGGLED
WITH THE MOST MONEY. AND THAT
WAS A HUGE SETBACK FOR HIM. SO
AT THE WORST TIME TO APPLY FOR
THE FOR AND PROGRAMS I BEGAN
ASKING QUESTIONS AND RESEARCHING
PROGRAMS AROUND. OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD AND THE SCHOOL.
FORTUNATELY I WAS ABLE TO FIND A
PROGRAM WITH PRETTY EARLY IN THE
PROCESS THE LIKE QUICKLY
COMMUNICATED WITH THEM THE
MINUTE OUR APPLICATION. AND MY
FAMILY MET THE ELIGIBILITY
CRITERIA SO I WAS ABLE TO GET
THE KIDS IN AN AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAM AT NO COST PLUS. WITH
THE BLESSING. AND I'M BARELY
STARTING TO FOCUS ON MYSELF OF
MY FAMILY. MAKE THEM GROW AND
THEN. THE APPLICATION HOWEVER
FOR THEM TO GET THEM IN THOSE
PROGRAMS WAS NOT EASY THERE WAS
A LOT OF REQUIRED BEFORE BACKING
FOR COMMUNICATION WITH THE
STAFF- KOBE MADE IT VERY
DIFFICULT BECAUSE- THE
ACCESSIBILITY AND LIMITED HOURS
AND FAT STORAGE SHORTAGES THAT
THERE WERE- BUT I MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAD EVERYTHING AT THE END
OF IT. THE COMPLETE EVERYTHING
IN ONE BECAUSE. IT HAPPENS A LOT
THE BILLABLE. ALTHOUGH I VERY TO
HAVE HAD ACTED AT THE LOCAL AT
MY SON'S ELEMENTARY SCHOOL. IT
WAS CLEAR THAT THEY WERE. ARE
YOU LIMITED IN WHAT THEY CAN
OFFER BECAUSE THE EXHIBITION
FUNDING AND STAFF SHORTAGES.
THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO HELP MY
FRIEND HIS MARK. AS THEY ONLY
HAD ENOUGH STAFF MEETING THE
BASIC THE PROVISION OF CHILDREN
AND NOT OFFERING ONE ON ONE FOR
. ALTHOUGH I DON'T EXPECT HIM TO
HELP HIM S MUCH I DO- YOU KNOW
THAT IT MAKES THINGS A LITTLE
HARDER FOR US. OUR DAYS ARE
REALLY LONG. NOT ON BOARD FOR
FIRST GRADERS ALONG OTHER
CHILDREN- WHEN THE WHOLE THEY'RE
BASICALLY OVER. AND THEN THE
SEVERAL HOURS IN THE AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAM IS DIFFICULT I
ALSO KNOW THAT MY SON IS A VERY
FIFTY BODY. AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM
THAT HAS INCORPORATED PHYSICAL
ACTIVITY. THE GETTING USED TO
HIS BODY WOULD BE GREAT. AND
ALSO GOOD FOR HIS HEALTH. IN A
PERFECT WORLD AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS WOULD BE FUNDED BALANCE
THE PHYSICAL ACTIVITIES WITH
HOMEWORK SUPPORT IF YOU GET THE
CHANCE TO START THEIR BODIES AND
BRAINS. AGAIN I DON'T BLAME THE
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM TEACHER
THEY DO A GREAT JOB WITH MY SON.
BUT IT'S NOT FAIR TO EXPECT THEM
TO BUY THE WHOLE POINT OF IT ALL
THAT MUCH. I JUST WISH THAT THEY
HAD THE RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
SUPPORT IT CHILD'S INDIVIDUAL.
AS I MENTIONED MY FINEST BEHIND
ACADEMICALLY AND HAVE THE
NINETY. WHICH IS NEEDED TO GET
SERVICES. THE SERVICES NEEDED TO
TRANSITION THE JANUARY BUT HE
HAD BEEN ABLE TO GET THEM.
BECAUSE OF THE STAFF SHORTAGE
AND THE LACK OF RESOURCES. I'M
CONCERNED THAT I WASN'T WHAT
ABOUT THIS RECENTLY- AND IN ALL
HONESTY I WAS UNDER THE
IMPRESSION THAT NINETY EIGHT
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
IN WRITING AND IT'S A BINDING
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE FAMILY. OR
THE DISTRICT. ACCORDING TO THE
SCHOOL. THERE AREN'T ENOUGH
RESOURCES OR STAFF TO HELP MY
CHILD WITH ME. IT HAS BEEN VERY
DISHEARTENING AND DEVASTATING.
BUT I'M TRYING MY BEST ADVOCATE
MY FRIEND AND I WILL DO THAT ALL
ALWAYS. WELL MY TWENTY FIRST
GRADE MY DAUGHTER STILL IN
PRESCHOOL ALTHOUGH SHE WAS
ELIGIBLE I WAS NOT ABLE TO GET A
FALL FOR HER AND IF HE YOU NEAR
OUR HOME. AND WE WILL OFFER TO
BUY ACROSS TOWN THANK. I REALLY
THINK PRIORITY SHOULD BE GIVEN
HELLO HOTEL DEPARTURE FOR AN
OLDER SIBLING OR NOTHING FOUR OR
EIGHT. AT THE VERY LEAST THE
NEAREST YOU OR NEAR THEIR
RESIDENCE. BUT THE FULL
PLACEMENT FROM MY UNDERSTANDING
OF SOMETHING THAT THE FABRIC
FOR. DISTRICT HAS HAD A BIG
CHALLENGE WHAT. I COMMUNICATED A
WHILE AGO WITH THE PEOPLE NEAR
OUR HOME WHICH I HAD BEEN ON A
WAIT LIST FOR TWO YEARS. AND
LAST YEAR I GOT A CALL THAT
THERE WAS A BIG OPEN. BY
COMMUNICATED WITH THE TICKET FOR
THAT MY DAUGHTER WAS INVOLVED IN
. THE DROP HER ATTENDANCE AND
THAT WAS AN ISSUE IN ITSELF.
ALTHOUGH I WASN'T GOING TO BE
PROBLEMATIC THE REALITY WAS THAT
I NEEDED THE PEACE OF MIND AND
HAVING FOUR KIDS IN DIFFERENT
SCHOOLS AND FAR FROM EACH OTHER.
IT'S JUST A BIG BURDEN FOR OUR
FAMILY. I FEEL FORTUNATE TO HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO GET A FAITH IN THE
PEOPLE PROVIDED BOTH FOR
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN OUR HOME.
SO IT TOOK SEVERAL EMAIL CALL.
MAKE THAT CHANGE BUT I WOULD
PREFER THAT I WOULD BE ABLE TO
DO IT. WITHOUT THAT IF YOU WOULD
HAVE BEEN MUCH MORE STRESSFUL
ESPECIALLY WITH GAS PRICES.
BEING AT ALL TIME HIGH. I WOULD
HAVE TO DRIVE OR FIND
TRANSPORTATION FOR DIFFERENT
PART OF THE CITY AND STRUGGLE
WITH THAT. JUST TO CARE FOR MY
DAUGHTER. OR SPEND TIME AND
ENERGY FIFTEEN PER PROVIDER FOR
FIGHTING THE CHANGES THAT MET MY
FAMILY. THIS SYSTEM AS IT IS SET
UP BASICALLY CALLED GUARANTEE
FIGURE OUT A- THEIR OWN.
FORTUNATELY MY KIDS ARE CLOSE IN
AGE. THAT'S THIS CALL CAN
CONTACT THIS TALENTED BUT THEN
THERE'S ALSO THE BENEFITS OF
THAT TOO. BUT I KNOW IT'S EVEN
HARDER FOR PARENTS WITH MORE OF
AN AGE GAP BETWEEN THEIR KID. IF
MY DAUGHTER WAS TWO FOR EXAMPLE
I KNOW I WOULD HAVE A LOT MORE
MORE TO WORRY ABOUT. IT'S REALLY
A POINT TO HAVE A DEVELOPMENT.
FINANCE DEVELOPMENTALLY
APPROPRIATE HEALTHCARE FOR KIDS
OF ALL AGES. NEARBY PRESCHOOL
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL MIDDLE SCHOOL.
HIGH SCHOOL THE PARENTS WOULD
HAVE TO TRAVEL FAR. OR WAIT ON
WE LISTS TO HELP CARE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN. THIS IS WHY IT'S
CRITICAL TO RAISE THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS AS WE ADD MORE STOCK.
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATED WITH THE PANDEMIC AND
EVEN BEFORE THAT. THEY WERE
SEVERELY UNDER EIGHT. IF WE
DON'T RAISE THE REIMBURSEMENT
RATE PROVIDERS WILL CONTINUE TO
CLOSE AND IT WILL BE EVEN HARDER
FOR FAMILIES. FOR FAMILIES LIKE
MINE TO FIND HEALTH CARE FOR
THEIR YOUNG. WHEN YOU BUY THE
HOME. THANKS TO THE WORK FOR THE
BOARD OF THE OLDER KIDS. AS I
SAID I FEEL FORTUNATE TO HAVE
BOTH OF MY KIDS LEARNING- FOR.
NEAR ONE ANOTHER. I CAN'T
BELIEVE THAT IT TOOK A LOT OF MY
TIME AND EFFORT TO MAKE THAT
WORK. AND NOW. THAT'S NOT HOW IT
SHOULD BE. I ALSO HAVE CONCERNS
OF MAKING THAT CHANGE DEPENDING
WHICH MY DAUGHTER FROM T. CASE.
I'M A TEACHER OKAY GREAT C. K.
TO A PREPAY BECAUSE I THOUGHT
THAT SHE WOULD PROBABLY LEARN
MORE MORE STUFF IN. A SETTING
BUT- WHEN I PUT. YOU WITH THE
COMMUTE AND TRANSPORTATION
AFFECT MY FAMILY. BUT OVERALL
SYSTEM THE OFFICE WOULD BE FOR.
I ALSO KNOW THAT IT'S NOT THE
CASE SAM. HOWEVER AND I HOPE
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY MAKE THINGS
EASIER FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
FAMILIES TO HELP THEM WITH THEIR
NEEDS FOR THE FAMILY BY IN A
WORLD WHERE THERE'S- SO MUCH
UNCERTAINTY BUT YET I HOLD ON
FOR A LOT OF HOPE. THAT THINGS
WILL WORK OUT. AND THEN MAKE A
LEFT MANY CHILDREN AT A
DISADVANTAGE WITH REGARD TO
MENTAL SOCIAL HEALTH. AND
ECONOMIC ISSUES SUCH AS MARTIN
LAW. AND THAT IS WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR CHILDREN TO HAVE
THE RESOURCES THEY NEED. TO HAVE
A HOLISTIC APPROACH IN ORDER FOR
THEM TO THRIVE. IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT HI. AND IN IT. AT
THE CENTRAL. I'M THE CHARACTER
HELP THE CAMPUS IS WITH EVERY
PENNY THEY ARE OUR FUTURE. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
ALLOWING ME TO SHARE MY STORY.
THANK YOU MISS MARQUEZ WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND YOUR
STORY AS WELL. MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO OUR LAST PANEL
WHICH INCLUDES PARTNERSHIP FOR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH AND THE CHILD
CARE RESOURCE CENTER WELCOME
WE'LL BEGIN WITH MS GUNDERSEN
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. THE MORNING MEMBERS I'M JUST
GONNA PULL UP AND A POWER POINT
TO GIVE ME ONE MOMENT. THANK YOU. GREAT GOOD MORNING MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JESSICA GUNDERSEN WITH
THE PARTNERSHIP FOR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH THE PARTNERSHIP FOR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH IS AN
ADVOCACY AND CAPACITY BUILDING
ORGANIZATION. DEDICATED TO A
FUTURE WHERE ALL CHILDREN REACH
THEIR FULL POTENTIAL THROUGH
EQUITABLE ACCESS. TO LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES AND SUPPORT OF
SCHOOLS. WE ALSO COORDINATE THE
AFTERSCHOOL CALIFORNIA AFTER
SCHOOL ADVOCACY ALLIANCE A
COALITION OF EXPANDED LEARNING
PROVIDERS AND CHILD ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SERVE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES. EVERYDAY RELY ON
PUBLICLY FUNDED EXPANDED
LEARNING PROGRAMS. I'M AND WHILE
MY COLLEAGUE AND I ARE GOING TO
DISCUSS SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
WHICH MUCH OF WHAT YOU'VE
ALREADY HEARD AND THE POLICY
OPPORTUNITIES WE REALLY WANT TO
START WITH THE BIG OPPORTUNITIES
BEFORE US AND REALLY THINK THE
LEGISLATURE. ON ALL THE MEMBERS
HERE TODAY AND THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR FIRST AND
FOREMOST HUGE INVESTMENTS THAT
MANY OF US HAVE BEEN FIGHTING
DECADES FOR TO PROVIDE HIGH
QUALITY EARLY LEARNING CARE AND
EXPANDED LEARNING PROGRAMS TO
ALL FAMILIES. THESE INVESTMENTS
HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO BE A GAME
CHANGER TO ENSURE ALL STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES THRIVE AND SUCCEED
IN CALIFORNIA REGARDLESS OF
INCOME GEOGRAPHY AND RACE. WE
ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION I WAS RECOGNIZING
THAT NON ACADEMIC FACTORS. SUCH
AS HEALTH SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING TRAUMA ACCESS TO
ENRICHMENT AND PLAY. ARE AS
IMPORTANT AS TRADITIONAL
SCHOOLING. TO REALLY MEANING
PLEASE CLOSE GAPS AND IMPROVE
OUTCOMES FOR ALL KIDS. AND
LASTLY WE APPRECIATE THE EFFORT
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS- IN
ADMINISTRATION AND IN FUNDING.
TO SEEK TO INTEGRATE. AND BLOOD
AND BRAVES WIDE VARIETY OF
PROGRAMS THAT YOU HEARD- THAT'S
SAD YOU KNOW WHOLE CHILD FULL
DAY IN FULL YEAR APPROACH IS AN
IDEAL AND IT REALLY WILL REQUIRE
NEW WAYS OF OPERATING AND SPACE
FOR INNOVATION. AND AS WE ALL
KNOW STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES
ARE KIND OF LIKE GIANT TAKERS
AND NEW WAYS OF BUSINESS WILL
TAKE TIME. AND REALLY AN ALL
HANDS ON DECK APPROACH SO ONE I
JUST THINK WE NEED TO KEEP IN
MIND THAT THIS IS A TIME OF
TRANSITION AND I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE PANELISTS THAT CAME
BEFORE ME WHO ARE REALLY EXPERTS
IN THE SPACE AND I'VE LEARNED SO
MUCH FROM AND I HOPE. THAT AS
THINGS BEGIN TO OPEN UP MEMBERS
AND STAFF THAT ARE LISTENING
TODAY MAKE SURE THAT YOU GET OUT
THERE AND GO SEE YOUR PROVIDERS
IN ALL THESE DIFFERENT EXCITING-
FOR THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS THE
PARTNERSHIP FOR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH. ARM AND THE CHILD CARE
RESOURCE CENTER HAVE BEEN
CONDUCTING RESEARCH. I'D BEEN
BEATING DOZENS OF STATE AND
LOCAL EXPERTS- AROUND A REAL
LONG OVERDUE COMING TOGETHER
BETWEEN OUR SECTORS THAT HAVE SO
MUCH IN COMMON- AND THEN WE
STARTED THIS WORK BEFORE KOBE
OUR PARTNERSHIP WAS REALLY
STRENGTHENS- WHEN OUR SECTORS
WERE DETERMINED TO BE
EXCEPTIONAL WHICH WE ALWAYS KNEW
ESPECIALLY CHILDCARE AND BOTH OF
OUR WORK FORCES I CANNOT SAY
THIS ENOUGH ON THE FRONT LINES.
CARING FOR KIDS EVEN WHEN
SCHOOLS OPERATED REMOTELY. SO I
WANT TO BRING UP THE SLIDE THAT
REALLY STARTS WITH. THE POSITIVE
WHICH IS OUR SECTORS HAVE MUCH
MORE IN COMMON THAN KNOCKS I'M
NOT GONNA READ. ALL EVERYTHING
LISTED HERE BUT WHAT I WANT
FOLKS TO SEE IS THAT BOTH THE
EXPANDED LEARNING SECTOR AND THE
EARLY LEARNING AND CHILDCARE
SECTOR HAVE ASSETS SO WE KNOW
THAT THE C. HAS REALLY REALLY
STRONG. QUALITY ASSESSMENTS AND
TOOLS THEY HAVE A WIDE VARIETY
OF MODELS FOR FAMILIES AS WELL
AND THEY HAVE A DEEP HISTORY OF
REALLY HAVING A FAMILY FOCUS AND
THEN YOU LOOK AT THE EXTENDED
LEARNING PROGRAMS AND THEY HAVE
A VERY STRONG LINK TO THE SCHOOL
DAY. AND THERE'S A LOT OF
BENEFITS WIN PROGRAMS CAN BE
OPERATED WHEN ADAMS SCHOOL SITES
AS WELL- AND THOUGH WE HAD WE
TEND TO HAVE MORE PART TIME
WORKERS AS WELL. AND THEN LET'S
FOCUS ON REALLY THE INTERSECTION
WHICH IS AGAIN WHILE WE ARE WHY
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT APPROACHING
FAMILIES MORE HOLISTICALLY- AS
WELL AS- HOW MUCH THESE SECTORS
HAVE IN COMMON RIGHT I'M REALLY
THESE SECTORS ARE FOUNDED ON
PRIORITIZING THOSE MOST
UNDERSERVED. CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES. WE HAVE A VERY DIVERSE
AND COMMUNITY GROUNDED WORK
FORCE WHICH IS A HUGE ASSET-
BOTH OF OUR SECTORS ARE REALLY
GROUNDED AND CHILD AND YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT- AND WE ALL KNOW.
THAT DOSAGE IN QUALITY MATTERS
WHICH IS WHY RATES MATTER SO
MUCH- WE ALSO HAVE A LOT OF
SHARED CHALLENGES WHEN IT COMES
TO COMPENSATION SO REALLY
FOUNDATIONAL LEVI DO HAVE MORE
IN COMMON THAN NOT- THAT BEING
SAID YOU KNOW JUST BECAUSE WE
HAVE A LOT IN COMMON DOESN'T
MEAN IT MAKES IT EASY TO BLEND
IN GRAY. WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE
WORKING TOWARDS SO. YOU'VE HEARD
AN OVERVIEW OF THE PROGRAM- AS
WE WORKED OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS. WE STARTED TO TRY TO
DEVELOP A MAP BECAUSE- JUST TO
ILLUSTRATE WHAT THIS MAZE IS
THAT I KNOW THERE'S A LOT COMING
OUT MEMBERS AND STAFF BUT- I
WANT TO SEE THAT AS YOU LOOK
FROM LEFT TO RIGHT WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO SEE IS LIKE WHAT IS
THE CONTINUE M. FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE. AND AS THEY GET OLDER
AND IF YOU THIS MAZE IS
DIFFICULT FOR US TO SEE IF YOU
CAN ONLY IMAGINE WHAT IT MIGHT
BE FOR A FAMILY- OR AN
ADMINISTRATOR OF THESE PROGRAMS
AND SO SOME OF THE THINGS I WANT
TO CALL OUT HERE IS. WHEN YOU
LOOK AT AGES I MEAN RATES
THERE'S REALLY A WIDE VARIETY OF
RATES- THOSE CHILDCARE IS
UNDERFUNDED THEY AT LEAST
ACCOUNT FOR REGIONAL DIFFERENCES
THAT'S SOMETHING YOU HAVEN'T
SEEN OR HEARD OF IT AFTER SCHOOL
FOR A WHILE- AND SO. ANY ONE OF
THESE ADMINISTRATORS MIGHT HAVE
TO TAKE ON ALL TEN OF THESE
PROGRAMS AND THE EXPECTED
EXPECTED TO BLEND IN BRAID- AND
AGAIN. RIGHT NOW. WE'RE NOT
ALWAYS ALLOWED TO BLEND IN
GREATER WORKFORCE FOR EXAMPLE
THE QUALIFICATIONS ARE DIFFERENT
SO WHY WE HAVE THESE HUGE
STAFFING CHALLENGES. SOME OF OUR
PROGRAM PROVIDERS ARE UNABLE TO
. EVEN MAKE SHORT TERM
SUBSTITUTION- BECAUSE OF SOME OF
THE PROGRAMMER FIVE MINUTES
AGAIN THESE REQUIREMENTS ARE IN
PLACE FOR A REASON BUT WE MIGHT
NEED TO STEP BACK AND RETHINK
THINGS IF WE ARE ASKING FOLKS TO
BLEND IN GRADE MORE AND MORE.
YOU CAN ALSO SEE THAT THIS
VARIETY OF PROGRAMS ARE OVERSEEN
BY DIFFERENT ADMINISTRATING
AGENCIES AND SO WHEN YOU ADD A
LOT OF DIFFERENT. ADMINISTRATIVE
AGENCIES YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT
THE BURDEN THAT CAN HAPPEN ON
PROVIDERS WHO AGAIN ARE TRYING
TO FOCUS ON THE WHOLE CHILD. THE
WHOLE FAMILY APPROACH- AND SO
AGAIN WHILE WE THINK BLENDING
AND BRAIDING SOUNDS GOOD AND IS
THE RIGHT THING TO DO IT'S NOT
AS EASY AS WE MAKE IT SEEM SO WE
HOPE- AFTER THIS HEARING FOLKS
CAN I DID GET A LITTLE BIT MORE
TO THIS ROAD MAP AND THINK ABOUT
HOW DO WE REMOVE. AND BARRIERS-
AND SOME OF THE BLOCKS TO COME
IN THINKING MORE HOLISTICALLY SO
WITH THAT I'M GONNA PASS IT OFF
TO THE CHILD CARE RESOURCE
CENTER TO CLOSE THIS OUT WITH
SOME HIGH LEVEL POLICY ISSUES
AND OPPORTUNITIES. THAT THE
COMMITTEE CAN CONSIDER THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MS GUNDERSEN
BEFORE WE GET TO YOU MESSNER
INJURE I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
IS A GREAT CHART AND I LOVE YOUR
POINT ABOUT IT'S HARD FOR US TO
LOOK AT AND FIGURE IT OUT HOW IN
THE WORLD IS APPARENT NAVIGATE
THAT SO. FEW THAT BE HELPFUL
GOING FORWARD. MS DONNA SKINNER. INJURE PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THE MORNING ALMOST
AFTERNOON. I'M GONNA SALINGER
AND I AM THE CHIEF STRATEGY
OFFICER AT THE CHILD CARE
RESOURCE CENTER. THANK YOU SO
MUCH SENATOR FOR CONVENING THIS
pISSUE WE'VE ALL WORKED ON. FOR
THE PAST FEW YEARS AS JESSICA
MENTIONED. CCRC IS A NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION AND
OUR MISSION IS TO CULTIVATE
CHILD FAMILY AND COMMUNITY
WELLBEING. WE ACHIEVE THESE
GOALS BY ADMINISTERING A VARIETY
OF STATE. FEDERAL AND LOCALLY
FUNDED PROGRAMS INCLUDING CHILD
CARE RESOURCE AND REFERRAL.
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT CAL WORKS
SUBSIDIES HEAD START AND A
VARIETY OF FAMILY RESOURCE AND
WELL BEING SERVICES INCLUDING
HOME VISITING MENTAL HEALTH
CONSULTATION AND RESOURCE. I WE
PROVIDE SERVICES FOR CHILDREN
BIRTH OR- BIRTH THROUGH SCHOOL
AGE AND THAT WAS REALLY WHAT
BROUGHT US TO THE TABLE WITH P.
C. Y. AS WE STARTED TO SEE. SO
MANY CHALLENGES EMERGING
CONSISTENTLY ACROSS THE FULL
CONTINUUM. I'M WE ENTERED THIS
UP WITH EYES WIDE OPEN- WE KNEW
THIS WAS GOING TO BE A
COMPLICATED CONVERSATION. AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE LABELING
OF A PLANT THAT MIKE ERA.
BECAUSE I DO FEEL LIKE BOTH THE
CHILDCARE AND EARLY LEARNING
SLASH THE- SECTORS ARE SWIMMING
IN PLANNING RIGHT NOW. AND A LOT
OF UNKNOWNS AND SO I'M GOING TO
START OFF BY LOOKING UP SPECIFIC
PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED. AND THEN I'M GOING
TO MOVE INTO SOME POLICY ISSUES
AND OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE ON
THE ROAD A HAT. FIRST AND
FOREMOST I'M THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDENS PLACED ON BOTH- ELEAZAR
AND COMMUNITY BASED OPERATORS
WHO ARE TRYING TO NAVIGATE THAT
GRAPHIC THAT YOU JUST LOOKED AT-
AND- CLEARLY WE'RE STRUGGLING TO
TRY TO MAKE IT LOOK LIKE A
SEAMLESS SYSTEM TO PARENTS. BUT
IT'S ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE WITH THE
RULES THAT WERE GIVEN. THEY
CREATE SYSTEMS WHICH WERE LIFTED
UP BY CARLOS NINOS WHERE YOU
HAVE KIDS WHO CAN ONLY BE IN ONE
PART OF THIS A PROGRAM BECAUSE
THE FUNDING THAT'S RECEIVED
THERE WERE SECTIONING KIDS OFF
FROM EACH OTHER- MAYBE TOGETHER
DURING SCHOOL DURING THE DAY.
AND THAT'S OFTEN HAPPENING BASED
ON THESOCIO ECONOMICS OF THEIR
FAMILY. I'M STUDENT SOME
PROVIDERS ARE TREATED AND
EQUALLY FOR COMPARABLE TYPES OF
SERVICE DEPENDING ON THE DOOR
THEY ENTER. WE HAVE MAJOR
STAFFING SHORTAGES BOTH FOR
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION THAT
UNDERMINED THE ABILITY. TO
EXPAND ACCESS AND PROVIDE
PROFESSIONAL STABILITY TO OUR
WORKFORCE AND CONSISTENCY OF
CARE TO OUR KIDS. THE DUKE THERE
ARE DUPLICATIONS OF STATE LOCAL
ADMINISTRATIVE ROLES IN
SUFFICIENT AND DISCONNECTED DATA
TRACKING WE'RE NEVER TALKED
ABOUT IN THE SAME CONVERSATION.
SO WE'RE ALWAYS TRYING TO PIECE
IT TOGETHER AFTER THE FACT. WE
HAVE SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS
BECAUSE OF PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT. OUR PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT REALLY LIMITS WHAT ELEAZAR
CAN DO HOW COMMUNITY BASED
PROVIDERS CAN BE INVOLVED AND
HOW WE CAN SHARE AND LEVERAGE
RESOURCES. AND I THINK
PARTICULARLY AS WE LOOK AT
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL AND HOW
WE'RE GOING TO MAXIMIZE OUR
SYSTEMWE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
TACKLE THIS CONVERSATION IT'S A
PAINFUL CONVERSATION. I KNOW NO
ONE LIKES THE- STATION BUT IT IS
DEFINITELY THE ELEPHANT IN THE
ROOM. WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THESE
SYSTEMS. WE ALSO HAVE CAN IN
OVER TIMELINE AND REQUIREMENTS
TO IMPLEMENT CHANGES. WE HAVE-
CHALLENGES WHERE WE REALLY DO
NEED TO OFFER A FULL WORK DAY
AND YEAR FOR WORKING PARENTS.
AND WE'RE EXCITED THAT THE EARLY
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES PROGRAM
IS STARTING TO LOOK AT NINE HOUR
DAYS AND STARTING TO LOOK AT NON
OPERATIONAL DAYS OF SCHOOL. BUT
IT HAS TO BE ALL OF THOSE DAYS
IT CAN'T JUST BE THIRTY
ADDITIONAL DAYS. I PERSONALLY
WHEN MY DAUGHTER WAS IN-
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL SUMMER IS THE
HARDEST TIME FOR PARENTS WHO
HAVE AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL CHILD.
AND IF THEY DON'T HAVE A
CONSISTENT ENROLLMENT AT A CHILD
CARE PROGRAM AND THEY'RE TRYING
TO GO OUT AND FIND CAMP OPTIONS
OR OTHER OPPORTUNITIES IT'S
REALLY A CHALLENGE. AND LASTLY
IN THE PROBLEM SECTION THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF MONEY THAT'S GONE
OUT TO LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES
TO BE PART OF THIS PLAN. BUT
THERE HAS BEEN NO MONEY GIVEN TO
THE EARLY CHILDHOOD SYSTEM TO
THE CHILD CARE SECTOR OR TOO
EARLY EXPANDED LEARNING TO SIT
AT THOSE TABLES. AND I CAN ONLY
SPEAK FROM MY OWN ORGANIZATION
AND SAYING THAT WE HAVE OVER
FORTY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN OUR SERVICE AREA THAT'S A LOT
OF TABLES. AND TO BE ABLE TO
EFFECTIVELY PARTNER AND BE THERE
I'M IN A WAY THAT WE WANT TO
SHOW UP WE CAN'T DO IT WITHOUT
SUPPORT. SO AS EVERYONE HAS
LIFTED UP WERE AT AN INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY MOMENTS WHERE THEN
FLEXION POINT WHERE PEOPLE
REALLY DO UNDERSTAND. THAT
FAMILIES NEED THESE SERVICES
CHILDREN NEED THESE SERVICES AND
WE ALL HAVE TO ROLL OUR SLEEVES
UP. AND WORK TOGETHER TO TRY TO
MAKE THIS BETTER. SO SOME OF THE
AREAS WHERE WE KNOW THERE ARE
IMMEDIATE OPPORTUNITIES- ARE.
CERTAINLY AROUND REIMBURSEMENT
RATES. I'M WE ARE CURRENTLY
LOOKING AT REIMBURSEMENT RATES
AND A VRIETY OF DIFFERENT TASK
FORCES AND WORKING GROUPS. NONE
OF THEM ARE LOOKING ACROSS THE
WHOLE CONTINUUM. EXPANDED
LEARNING IS LEFT OUT. THERE ARE
A DOLLARS NEEDED TO EXPAND THE
LEARNING BETTER AND ASK OF LOCAL
DISTRICTS TO BRING IN A MATCH.
AND WHAT YOU END UP AS WITH
TREMENDOUS INCONSISTENCIES ON
WHAT WE PAY FOR THE BIRTH OF
TWELVE CONTINUUM OF CARE. ONE OF
THE EXAMPLES THAT I WANTED TO
LIVE I HAVE IS FOR THE SAME AGE
CHILD SO A SCHOOL AGE CHILD A
TWO SECOND GRADER. IF THEY'RE IN
AN EXPANDED LEARNING PROGRAM THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE IS ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR. IF
THEY'RE IN THE SAME. PART TIME
PROGRAM IN A CHILD CARE SYSTEM
THE STATE REIMBURSEMENTS CLOSER
TO TEN THOUSAND PER YEAR THAT'S
A HUGE GAP IT'S A HUGE GAP AND
IT CHANGES WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO
OFFER. THE OTHER THING THAT WE
ARE REALLY WORKING THROUGH AND
WANT TO TALK TO POLICYMAKERS
ABOUT. IS HOW DO WE HANDLE THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE PARTICULARLY
AROUND UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL AND
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN THE
NEEDS OF YOUNG ELEMENTARY
STUDENTS AND TK'S STUDENTS ARE
NOT. NECESSARILY A GOOD FIT FOR
WHAT OUR TRADITIONAL AFTER
SCHOOL MODEL HAS BEEN WITH
HIGHER STAFFING RATIOS- THEY ARE
NOT OLDER ELEMENTARY KIDS
THEY'RE NOT SELF DIRECTED THERE
NOT AT AN AGE WHERE THEY CAN DO
THINGS INDEPENDENTLY. HOW ARE WE
GOING TO SET UP AN AGE
APPROPRIATE SYSTEM WHERE THOSE
CHILDREN RECEIVE THE APPROPRIATE
SUPERVISION AND CARE AND ARE IN
A SAFE ENVIRONMENT AFTER SCHOOL.
WE ALSO NEED TO INCLUDE. A NEW
VISION FOR BUILDING THE WORK
FORCE A LOT OF THIS IS REALLY
HINGES ON HOW MUCH WE PAY PEOPLE
IF WE DON'T PAY PEOPLE A
REASONABLE WAGE. LET ALONE A
LIVING WAGE- WE CAN'T RECRUIT
PEOPLE INTO THIS INDUSTRY AND WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH. SO I THINK
IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE REALLY THINK ABOUT. THE
WORKFORCE WERE BRINGING AND HOW
WE IDENTIFY PEOPLE WHO HAVE AN
INTEREST IN INTENTIONALITY AND
SKILLS IN WORKING WITH YOUNG
CHILDREN. AND HOW WE INCLUDE
THEM IN WHATEVER SYSTEM IT IS
WE'RE GOING TO BUILD. WE ARE-
LOOKING AT THE MASTER PLANNED
FOR EARLY LEARNING AND MANY OF
US HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
CONTINUING EFFORT WE'RE
DISAPPOINTED THAT EXPANDED
LEARNING WAS NOT INCLUDED. IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT THIS WE LOOK AT THE
WHOLE SYSTEM AND THE WHOLE
CONTINUUM OF CARE BECAUSE IF YOU
MAKE CHANGES ONLY ONE AGE GROUP.
OR IN ONLY ONE PROGRAM THERE ARE
RIPPLE EFFECTS THAT ARE FELT
OUT. AND TO MAKE CHANGES AND
IGNORE THAT- IS SURE IT IT
LEAVES US COMING UP SHORT ALL OF
THE TIME. WE REALLY ENCOURAGE
THAT THERE BE POLICIES
CONSIDERED TO REQUIRE INSTEAD OF
INCENTIVIZE DATA SHARING
TECHNICAL SYSTEMS AND
COLLABORATIVE MESSAGING- WE LIVE
ACROSS TWO STATE AGENCIES.
ALWAYS HAVE MY GUESS IS ALWAYS
WELL AND IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE
ALL WORK TOGETHER TO TRY TO DO
THAT. AND I'M- YOU KNOW I'VE
BEEN STUDYING THIS FOR A LONG
TIME AND I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
IMAGINE IF YOUR FAMILY AND
YOU'RE TRYING TO UNDERSTAND AND
NAVIGATE. SO IF THE OTHER AREAS
FOR POTENTIAL- ASSISTANCE WOULD
BE TO CONSIDER MORE ONE TIME
FUNDS. AND GOINGDIRECTLY TO
CEOS TO HELP THEM BE AT THESE
TABLES AND BUILD OUT THESE
PROGRAMS. AND LOOK AT PROTECTING
FUNDING TO ALLOW IT TO ROLL OVER
AND EXTENDABLE IMITATION
TIMELINE. I THINK OU HEARD FROM
ALL OF OUR SERVICE OPERATORS
THERE UNDER THE GUISE. AND THEY
NEED MORE TIME AND MORE
EXPERTISE. AND WE NEED TO GIVE
THEM THE TIME TO DO THAT. AND
LASTLY DURING THIS OVERWHELMING
AND EXCITING EXPANSION OF T. K.
THE STATE. DO SOME WORK TO
CREATE HIGH LET'S. WITH THE
SUBSET OF ELEAZAR CBO'S AND CO
EASE- THAT WOULD INCREASE
FLEXIBILITY TO WAIVE CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS SO WE CAN TEST OUT
WHAT MIGHT WORK- YOU HAVE
ENGAGED OPERATORS YOU HEARD FROM
MANY OF THEM HERE TODAY WHO
WOULD BE WILLING TO TRY THINGS.
WE CAN LOOK AT REMOVAL OF
CERTAIN STAFFING REQUIREMENTS TO
SEE WHAT DIFFERENCE THAT MIGHT
MAKE HOW COULD WE LOOK AT THE-
REQUIREMENTS FOR C. C. T. ARE
THE CENTER BASED PROGRAMS AND
THEIR FACILITY REQUIREMENTS THAT
WOULD MAKE IT APPROPRIATE FOR
ALL THESE AGES. WE NEED TO ALLOW
PROGRAMS TO GROUP BY AGE NOT BY
FUNDING STREAMS WE CAN TRY THAT
OUT. AND WE NEED TO CREATE
INCENTIVES FOR L. E. A. N. C. B.
O. PARTNERSHIPS TO MAXIMISE
EQUITY AND LIFT UP THE WHOLE
CONTINUE I'M OF THE SYSTEM. WE
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE GOOD
THINKING THAT WENT INTO THE
STEERING AND THE TREMENDOUS
PALACE AND WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH DONNA YOU ALSO ARE SPOT
ON YOU TOTALLY GET THESE ISSUES
AND- WE REALLY APPRECIATE ALL OF
YOUR HELP AS WERE NAVIGATING-
HOW WE BEST CAN BE HELPFUL. ALL
RIGHT MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING INTO
QUESTIONS AND I WOULD LIKE TO
INVITE THE PUBLIC WANTING TO
PARTICIPATE TO CALL IN NOW.
PLEASE DIAL THE TOLL FREE NUMBER. 844-291-4185 WHEN PROMPTED.
PLEASE USE THIS ACCESS CODE.
FOUR SIX SIX THREE NINE SIX
EIGHT WE WILL NOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO OUR MEMBERS I
SEE SENATOR PAM AND THEN SENATOR
COOK CORTESE PLEASE PROCEED
SENATOR PAM YES. THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH AND AGAIN REALLY
APPRECIATE THE- THE
PRESENTATIONS WE HEARD TODAY AND
I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF- SYSTEMS
ISSUES AND ORGANIZATIONAL
ISSUES. BUT I DID WANT TO ASK A
QUESTION I THINK- HONEST MERRIER
TOUCHED A BIT ON THIS IT IS A
DEVELOPMENTAL PEDIATRICIAN AND-
FATHER. WHEN THINGS IS WE'RE
ROLLING OUT OUR EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION PROGRAM IS TO
RECOGNIZE THAT- THE FOCUS OF
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION IS A
BIT DIFFERENT- FOR TO BE
EFFECTIVE COMPARED TO WHAT WE
NEED FOCUS LET'S SAY AN OLDER
CHILDREN'S SCHOOL AS ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL KIDS- THE RESEARCH ON
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION. HAS
SHOWN THAT OF COURSE HAS A
TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON THE FUTURE
DEVELOPMENT BUT THAT IMPACT IS
ACTUALLY NOT THE FOCUS ON
ACADEMICS IT'S A FOCUS ON.
ESSENTIALLY SOCIALIZATION. N.
FACTORS SOME MORE RECENT
RESEARCH SHOWING THAT- PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN MORE FOCUSED ON
ACADEMICS EARLY ON ACTUALLY ARE
NOT HAVING THE LONG TERM RESULTS
THAT WE SAW WITH THE OTHER
RESEARCH THAT- THE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS. SO YES MY QUESTION
REALLY IS THAT AND I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF COMPLEXITIES
AND I ALSO HEARD FROM THE FOLKS
SAYING LIKE WE'RE TRANSPLANTED
UP THESE PROGRAMS VERY QUICKLY
AND SO FORTH. IS THAT HOW DO WE
ENSURE THAT. THE FOCUS OF THESE
PROGRAMS ARE DOING T. K. AND-
YOU KNOW ALL THESE OTHER THINGS
THAT IS ACTUALLY- THAT THE
PROGRAMS THEMSELVES ARE
PARTICULARLY FOCUSED ON-
SOCIALIZATION LET ME JUST GIVE
YOU ONE EXAMPLE IS AGAIN TALKING
ABOUT THE MORE RECENT RESEARCH.
IT WAS FASCINATING ABOUT IT WAS
THAT ONE OF THE THINGS HE
POINTED OUT WAS THAT IF THE
BATHROOMS ARE TOO FAR AWAY. AND
THE TEACHERS HAVE TO GROUP THE
KIDS TO GET THEM TO THE BATHROOM
AND STUFF WHAT MAKES THEM STAND
IN LINE SOMETHING THAT'S NOT A
BIG ISSUE IN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
THIS OVER REGIMENTATION THAT
COULD HAPPEN. JUST BECAUSE OF
THE STRUCTURAL WAY THE- THE
STRUCTURAL. LAYOUT OF THE
FACILITY. ACTUALLY YOU COULD
HAVE A NEGATIVE EFFECT OR TAKE
AWAY THE POSITIVE EFFECTOF.
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION. SO I
KNOW IT'S ALREADY COMPLICATED
ENOUGH AS IT IS NOW I'M TALKING
ABOUT WELL HOW DO YOU LAY OUT
YOUR FACILITIES HOW DO YOU TRAIN
YOUR TEACHERS BUT I DO WANNA BE
SURE THAT. WE ARE GETTING THE
MOST FROM OUR INVESTMENT IN THAT
WE ARE HAVING THE POSITIVE.
OUTCOMES THAT WE'VE THAT THE
PREVIOUS RESEARCH HAS SHOWN SO-
I'M NOT SURE WHO TO DIRECT A
QUESTION TO THE HEAD- YEAH I
DIDN'T. I GUESS I DIDN'T WANT TO
HEAR ABOUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO
INSURERS WERE YOU KNOW SPENDING
ON BASS MEANT THAT WE ARE
STRUCTURING THE PROGRAMS IN A
WAY. THAT HAS THE BEST BENEFIT
FOR THE KIDS THAT WERE ROLLING.
THANK YOU SENATOR PENN WE'LL
START WITH MRS NARINDER AND IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE WHO WANTS TO
JUMP IN PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND.
PLEASE GO AHEAD ON. I THINK
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR PAN
FOR A LIFTING UP ONE OF THE
THINGS I SPEND A LOT OF NIGHTS A
WEEK AND THINKING ABOUT. I WE
ARE. ALSO LOOKING VERY CLOSELY
AT THE RECENT RESEARCH THAT CAME
OUT ABOUT THE IMPACTS THE
UNINTENDED IMPACTS OF EARLY
ACADEMICS INCLUDING YOUNG
CHILDREN IN SETTINGS THAT WORKED
JUST FINE FOR THEM. AND I THINK
THAT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HAS
BEEN OF GREAT CONCERN TO ME IS
HOW DO WE- CREATE EARLY LEARNING
AND EXPANDED WORKING
ENVIRONMENTS THAT ARE.
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE. AND
DO ALL THE THINGS WE KNOW YOUNG
KIDS NEED- YOU KNOW I MADE MY
COLLEAGUES WILL LAUGH AT ME BUT
FOUR YEAR OLD CHILDREN THEY NEED
NAPS THEY NEED SNACKS THEY NEED
SOMEBODY TO CARE FOR THEM AND
THEY NEED SOMEBODY WHO'S GOING
TO YOU KNOW PICK THEM UP IF THEY
STUMBLE. AND PROVIDE THEM WITH
THE WARMTH AND CARING THAT IS
GOING TO HELP THEM GROW AND
DEVELOP AS YOU MENTIONED IN THE
SOCIAL SKILLS AND I THINK THAT
WE HAVE- A LOT OF WORK TO DO TO
THINK ABOUT OUR APPROACH TO
PRESCHOOL AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE ARE NOT GOING DOWN THE ROAD
OF PUTTING TOO MANY ACADEMICS IN
FRONT OF THESE CHILDREN TOO SOON
AND BURNING THEM OUT. AND I ALSO
WAS ALARMED BY THE SIMPLE THING
OF BATHROOMS LIGHT I HAVE TALKED
ABOUT TINY TOILET SO MUCH IN THE
PAST TEN YEARS I CAN'T EVEN
BEGIN TO TELL YOU HOW MUCH- BUT
IT DOES MATTER IT TEACHES
CHILDREN SELF REGULATION TEACHES
CHILDREN HOW TO MANAGE THEIR OWN
BODY. AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
MOST CONCERNS ME IS. WE'RE
MOVING MORE AND MORE YOUNG
CHILDREN INTO SETTINGS AND
PROGRAMS THAT WERE DESIGNED FOR
THAT. AND WE NEED TO HOLD UP
INVESTIGATORS AND LIFT UP THE
SPACES THAT WERE DESIGNED FOR
THEM AND EXPAND THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES. AND IT IS CLEARLY
PART OF THIS CONTINUE- AND I
THINK YOU SO MUCH FOR RAISING
THE THING THAT'S BEEN KEEPING ME
UP AT NIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISS NEAR INJURE AND WE ALSO
HAVE MISS CAPONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO COMMENT PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY- THANKYOU SO MUCH
FOR ASKING THE- THE QUESTION AND
DONNA I SO APPRECIATE YOUR
ANSWER- I THINK FOR TOO LONG
WE'VE ASKED. HOW DO WE PREPARE
SCHOOLS OUR CHILDREN TO BE READY
FOR SCHOOLS RATHER THAN ASKING
THE QUESTION OF HOW DO WE
PREPARE SCHOOLS TO BE READY. TO
RECEIVE THE CHILDREN WHO ARE
JOINING THEM- AS AN EARLY
EDUCATOR- I'VE BEEN AT THIS A
VERY LONG TIME AND- I'VE READ A
LOT OF RESEARCH AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT STICKS WITH ME
CONSISTENTLY. IS THE WORK OF A
CAUGHT SKI WHO SAYS THERE IS
NOTHING THAT WE LEARN OUTSIDE OF
THE CONTEXT OF A RELATIONSHIP.
AND IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT. EVEN
THE CONCEPT OF MORE CHILDREN
LEARN MORE WHEN THE CHILD BESIDE
THEM GETS MORE JUICE FIRST SNACK
VENDING. ALL OF OUR LEARNING
COMES IN THE SOCIAL
RELATIONSHIPS AND IF CHILDREN
AREN'T SUPPORTED TO DEVELOP
CLOSE SOCIAL RELATIONSHIPS. THAT
MAY LOSE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN WE HAVE OTHERS- JUST LIKE
WE FOCUS SO MUCH ENERGY ON WHAT
IS THE MATH SKILLS A CHILD NEEDS
TO LEARN WHAT IS THE LANGUAGE
SKILL IT CHILD NEEDS TO LEARN.
LEARNING SOCIAL SKILLS DON'T
HAPPEN BY CHANCE LEARNING HOW TO
BE PART OF THIS GROUP DOESN'T
HAPPEN BY CHANCE. LEARNING HOW
TO TAKE TURNS DOESN'T HAPPEN BY
CHANCE IT IS DIFFICULT WORK THAT
TAKES PLACE IN NURTURING
ENVIRONMENTS WHO'S- TASK IS TO
ME EMOTIONAL NEEDS OF CHILDREN
SO THEY BECOME INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
EMOTIONAL WORLD THAT SURROUNDS
THEM. BECAUSE IT IS NOT
EMOTIONAL WORLD THAT IS GOING TO
PROVIDE THE CONTEXT FOR
CURIOSITY AND INVESTIGATION. ON
AND I THINK THAT- WE HAVE TO
STOP ASKING ON DOES YOUR CHILD
KNOW THEIR LETTERS DOES THEY NOT
DO THEY KNOW THEIR NUMBERS THEY
WILL LEARN THEIR LETTERS AND
NUMBERS WHEN IT BECOMES
IMPORTANT TO THEM WITH IN A
SOCIAL CONTEXT. KIDS WANT TO
KNOW THEIR FRIENDS NAMES AND I
FOCUSED ON SOCIAL ENGAGEMENT AND
CHILD NAMES THEY'RE GOING TO
LEARN THAT DONNA'S NAME STARTS
WITH D. AND I'M GONNA BE EXCITED
ABOUT THAT NOT BECAUSE OF THE
LETTER D. BUT BECAUSE DONNA IS
MY FRIEND. AND SHE HER NAME IS
PART OF WHO SHE IS. THE OTHER
THING OUT JUST SAYING CLOSING
THIS MY BUTTON I COULD GO ON FOR
EVER BUT ONE OF THE THINGS ONE
WEEK KNOWLEDGE THE SOCIAL GROWTH
THAT OCCURS IN THE EARLY YEARS
IS WE BEGIN TO TEACH CHILDREN
THAT THEY ARE IMPORTANT. THEY
HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY AND THEY
ARE WORTH LISTENING TO. AND THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT IF YOU LOSE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SIT FOR
CHILDREN TO SEE THEMSELVES AS
POTENT. IN THIS WORLD. IN THE
EARLY. IT IS X. DIFFICULT FOR
THEM TO MAKE IT UP LATER. SO
SOCIAL SKILLS ARE THE JOB THE
WORK OF EARLY CHILDHOOD AND IT
IS A JOYFUL WORK. AS OPPOSED TO
IN THE MIDDLE WHERE NESS WHICH
NOT SO MUCH. ON SEPT THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY
OPINION. THANK YOU MS CAPONE A
VERY VERY GOOD WORDS SENATOR PAT
IF YOU HAVE ANYTHING ELSE YET. I
FIRST I JUST WANT TO REALLY
THINK. ABOUT IT THE ANSWERS- YET
AS A DEVELOPMENTAL PEDIATRICIAN
I WOULD SAY IS THAT THE RESEARCH
IS CLEAR- THAT. IS THEY BOTH
MENTIONED- SELF REGULATION
SOCIALIZATION AND THEY'RE
THEY'RE CRITICAL. PERIODS OF
DEVELOPMENT THAT AND- THAT. KNOW
THAT THAT PRESCHOOL AGE IT'S IT
REALLY IS OUT SOCIAL
SOCIALIZATION AND IN FACT IT HAS
A VERY LONG TERM IMPACTS IN
TERMS OF ABILITY YOU KNOW TO.
WENT WITH KIDS IN HIGH SCHOOL
AND BE ABLE TO GRADUATE HIGH
SCHOOL AND- THEIR CHANCES OF
GETTING A JOB LATER ON AND SO
FORTH. AND SO I JUST HOPE THAT
IS IN AND REALIZE THAT
EVERYONE'S WORKING REALLY HARD
AS WE'RE MAKING THESE
INVESTMENTS WERE HAVING THE
FOCUS WILL BE SURE WOULD DESIGN
THE PROGRAMS IN A WAY THAT
ADDRESSES THE ACT AND THE NEEDS
OF. THE CHILDREN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR PAN
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO SENATOR
CORTESE PLEASE PROCEED FURTHER
CORTESE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
GREAT CONVERSATION- IN A TWO I
SUPPOSE COULD MAKE COMMENTS AND
NUMBER AREAS BUT I WON'T TELL
YOU JUST HAVE. A QUESTION- THAT
GOES BACK TO ITEM TWO- UNIVERSAL
A PRESCHOOL AND- PARTICULARLY
IF. YEAH I GUESS THE TIME OF THE
HEARING IS SO GOOD- FROM MY
STANDPOINT- GIVEN THAT JUST IN
THE LAST FEW DAYS. WE'VE BEEN-
GETTING A LOT OF INCOMING
COMMENTARY FROM- ARE ARE THE
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOL
SUPERINTENDENTS- DOWN THE SAN
JOSE AREA ESPECIALLY IN EAST SAN
JOSE WERE- WE HAVE- LOW WEALTH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. AND ONE OF THE
GRANT PROGRAMS SPECIFICALLY THAT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING AROUND TODAY
THE UNIVERSAL PRE KINDERGARTEN
PLANE IMPLEMENTATIONGRANT YOU
KNOW HAS BEEN ALLOCATED- BUT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT HOW IT'S BEEN
ALLOCATED IN THE FORMULA WHICH I
THINK HAS BEEN AROUND FOR A LONG
TIME- IT REALLY. I THINK BRINGS
INTO QUESTION- THE QUESTION HOW
CAN WE ENSURE EQUITY ACROSS ALL
SCHOOLS IN IN TERMS OF OUR
FUNDING ALLOCATIONS IN IT. AS
YOU KNOW I DON'T THINK THIS IS-
ANY KIND OF TRADITIONAL. DEBATE
AROUND- CHARTERS VERSUS
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS SO I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT AS A SORT
OF A DISCLAIMER FIRST BUT THE
FORMULA. AS I READ IT IN I THINK
AS IT'S APPLIED UP FOR MUCH OF
THE OF THE GRANT PROGRAMS AGAIN
THAT HAVE BEEN REFERENCED TODAY
OR THAT ARE IN EXISTENCE IN THIS
IN THIS SPACE IN THIS AREA. THE
ESSENTIALLY- MAKE A CHARTER
SCHOOL AND L. E. A. A SINGLE
SCHOOL IN L. E. A SEWER DISTRICT
LIKE THE OLD ROCK SCHOOL
DISTRICT FOR EXAMPLE IN THE SAN
JOSE WITH TWELVE THOUSAND.
STUDENTS IN- MUCH OF A DISTRICT
IN COMMUNITIES OF CONCERN IT HAS
THE SAME EVIDENTLY THE SAME.
COMPETITIVE OPPORTUNITY IF YOU
WILL TO GET A SINGLE GRAD AS A
SINGLE SCHOOL WOULD GET- IF- IF
THEY'RE IN THE CHARTER SPACE SO
I DON'T WANT TO DEBATE THAT
TODAY. AND DO THAT I AM JUST
WONDERING IF I GUESS WHAT I'M
WONDERING IS THERE ARE PEOPLE
LOOKING AT THAT- OR THE LOOKING
AT THE ACTUAL OUTCOMES THAT
WE'RE GETTING WITH THE GRANT
DISTRIBUTION FOR FUTURE
REFERENCE- SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
SURE THAT- YOU KNOW WE ARE
GETTING EQUITY ACROSS THE BOARD.
THANK YOU MANAGER. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR CORTESE ARE WE
ARE HERE TO LEARN TODAY AND ALSO
TO GET QUESTIONS FROM OUR
MEMBERS SO THANK YOU THAT IS
HELPFUL. THOROUGH TROUBLED. GOOD
MORNING- MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES I AM- HUGE ADVOCATE
OF EARLY EDUCATION AND DIFFERENT
MODELS AND SO FORTH. BUT I DID
WANT TO COMMENT REALLY QUICK ON
SENATOR HANDS- EARLIER REMARKS.
I WANT TO INVITE MY COLLEAGUES
TO COME AND TO MY DISTRICT AND A
VISIT MONTESSORI IN REDLANDS AND
IF YOU'RE NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE
MODEL OF A MONTESSORI EDUCATION
IN THE CLASSROOM. I THINK YOU'LL
BE FASCINATED TO SEE- THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE NAPS PROVIDED THE
MONTESSORI CLASSROOM THEY ARE-
TOILETS THAT ARE THE SIZE OF YOU
KNOW ADEQUATE TO THE CHALLENGE
TO THE CHILD. BUT THAT ACTUAL%
LEARNING DOES TAKE PLACE
UNDERSTANDING THE DEVELOPMENTAL
- STATE OF THE BRAIN AND HOW AND
WHAT THEY LEARNED IN
SOCIALIZATION BEING A PART OF
THAT BUT MY CHILDREN HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEND AND I'M
VERY FAMILIAR WITH IT AND I
THINK. SEEING THAT MODEL IN
PLACE WOULD ACTUALLY- THE VERY
HELPFUL- FOR ALL OF US AS WE
MOVE FORWARD AND CONSIDER-
PROGRAMS AND RESOURCES TO OUR-
EARLY CHILD DEVELOPMENT- AND I
WELCOME ALL OF YOU TO COME AND
VISIT. THANK YOU SENATOR
TROUBLED MEMBERS ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SEEING
NONE WE ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE TO
OUR PUBLIC COMMENT WILL FIRST
SEE IT LOOK IN THE GALLERY
SEEING NO ONE HERE- LET US BEGIN
NOW. WITH WITNESSES WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL BEGIN.
THE MODERATOR WILL NOW ASK ALL
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT DEPARTMENT PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. THANK YOU MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE ME THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING TO
TESTIFY. MANAGER WE HAVE THREE
PEOPLE WAITING EXCELLENT IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE OPEN THE LINES AND
CALL THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
INDIVIDUAL INDIVIDUALLY WE WILL
CONTINUE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
WE SURE START WITH MY NUMBER
NINETEEN GO AHEAD. THANK YOU SO
MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR
LEYVA NUMBERS THANK YOU FOR
CONVENING THIS IMPORTANT HEARING
TODAY MY NAME IS DONNA HOFFMAN
COLIN AND I RECOMMEND COUNCIL%
FOR A STRONG AMERICA AND OUR
MEMBERSHIP AREN'T READY NATION
BY CRIME INVESTING KIDS MISSION
WRITING THAT. OUR MEMBERS WHO
ARE LEADERS IN BUSINESS LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND RETIRED MILITARY
ADVOCATE FOR POLICIES THAT KEEP
CHILDREN HEALTHY FAT AND
EDUCATED AND KNOW THE IMPORTANCE
OF BUILDING A CONTINUUM OF CARE
FOR FAMILIES. STARTING IN EARLY
CHILDHOOD AND CONTINUING
CRITICAL YEARS HIGH QUALITY
HEALTH CARE AND AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS HELP BUILD SAFER
COMMUNITIES AND A STRONGER
ECONOMY AND WEREN'T THE PORTABLE
GIVING BARRIERS TO ACCESS
STREAMLINING CARE AND DEVELOPING
A COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM TO GET
FAMILIES. THE CARE THEY NEED
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER MODERATOR FUEL MIX.
GO TO OUR NEXT PARTICIPANT
PLEASE. THANK YOU CHAIR LOCAL I.
NUMBER TO THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI LINE NUMBER TWENTY THREE OF
FIFTY EDUCATION COMMITTEE YEAH.
IN THE SENATE- I- POP ON HERE
FOR A QUICK MINUTE. I'M JUST
SAYING THAT I WAS THE WIFE OF AN
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATOR
KINDERGARTEN TEACHER IN THE
CANTON PUBLIC SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND THE MOTHER OF FOUR MYSELF
THE END OF THE- IN- ABOUT TO AGE
OUT OF KINDERGARTEN THIS IS BEEN
A PARTICULARLY FASCINATING
HEARING FOR ME THERE'S NO DOUBT
THAT EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
IS ARE THE BACKBONE OF HUMAN
DEVELOPMENT I'M PROBABLY THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING FOR HUMANS
DEVELOPING THE STOPPING POISONED
BY THE TOXIC VACCINE. I THINK
DOCTOR CAN. YOU KNOW PARADE ON
AND ON ABOUT PRETENDING TO BE-
YOU KNOW CONCERNED ABOUT EARLY
CHILDHOOD CONFIRM WHERE THE
BATHROOMS ARE MAY. BE THE MOST
INSISTENT ON LEAVING CHILDREN
YOU TALK ABOUT QUALITY AND
ACTUALLY MA'AM. I THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT. MONTEREY NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NATIONAL LINE TWENTY TWO
LINE TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
. YES I AM A MOTHER OF SIX AND I
HAVE HI MY CHILDREN IN ANY
MANNER AT EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION AND I. I'VE BEEN IN A
MONTESSORI PRESCHOOL WHICH I'M
ADMIT MY CHILDREN ONE OF WHOM
WENT TO A STATE FUNDED PRESCHOOL
AND THEN- FIVE WENT TO AMMAN.
FOR IN. MY EXPERIENCE AS A
MOTHER OF OKAY ON MY CHILDREN
THRIVE AND GET BETTER LONG TERM.
AND THE MONTESSORI SCHOOL THAT
HAD MORE OF THAT CHILD LED
APPROACH I'M HURT MY CHILD'S
LUNCH A STATE FUNDED. PRESCHOOL
AND HAD MORE OF THE CLASSICALLY
GERMAN APPROACH I MEAN A CHILD
LED APPROACH- COMING FROM A
PARENT'S PERSPECTIVE HAD
BENEFITED MIGHT BE MORE
BENEFICIAL TO MY CHILDREN. HI
LONG TERM DEBT AND SEEN THE
STATE FUNDED MORE ACADEMIA
DRIVEN APPROACH I'M. ONE OF MY
CHILDREN WHO WENT ON A STORY.
AND WHILE BARK ALL. ON THINK
HEALTH SCHOOL. HAD GONE ON. GET
A PARTIAL ACADEMIC SCHOLARSHIP
AND ALSO A PARTIAL ATHLETIC
SCHOLARSHIPS FOR COLLEGE SO I
FEEL LIKE HE CAN NOT STATE
FUNDED ACADEMIA PREQUEL AND
BOOKING ON A TRIAL LED. AT THREE
OVER THEIR LEARNING THROUGH PLAY
AND ACTUALLY IN MY EXPERIENCE
THERE'S ANOTHER EX MORE
BENEFICIAL THAN GOING FROM BEING
MORE SCHOLASTICALLY TRIP AND
THANK YOU THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS MR
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK. THE MANAGER
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE WOULD YOU-
GOOD THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
HAVING HEARD ALL CLOSE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. SEEING
NONE I WANT TO SINCERELY THANK
ALL OF OUR PANELISTS FOR BEING
HERE TODAY THIS IS THIS HELPS US
TO MAKE BETTER DECISIONS FOR OUR
EARLY CHILD CARE- PROVIDERS AS
WELL OF COURSE OUR CHILDREN. IF
YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO
US AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
THANK YOU EVERYONE AGAIN FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA IN THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED.